ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast, where
we discuss science and science
based tools for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today we are
discussing creativity.
Creativity is a topic that to
many people is very abstract.
That is, we know when something
seems creative, some of us
know people who are creative
or perhaps are creative,
and yet the ability to be
creative resides in everybody.
And we know that because
the neural circuits
that underlie creativity
have been somewhat defined
and the steps and processes
within the brain and body that
lead to creativity
are well known.
That said, most people don't
know how to access creativity.
And if they do know how
to access creativity,
they are only able
to access creativity
in a fairly limited
number of domains of life.
For instance, in the visual arts
or in music or within science
or engineering or any number
of different domains ranging
from the kitchen to sport
to childhood interactions.
That is, childhood games.
In other words, some
adults are able to access
their creative spirit when
engaging in childlike play
with children or for
that matter with adults.
But as it turns out,
all of creativity
stems from just a small
subset of neural structures
in the brain that
need to be activated
in a particular
sequence or order.
Today we will talk about what
those neural structures are,
what particular order they need
to be activated in in order
to come up with, for instance,
new ideas that are creative,
and then how to implement
those creative strategies.
We will also talk
about different ways
to access creativity
that include--
narrative and storytelling as
well as applying new rule sets
or even entirely new worldviews.
And we will do this in
a structured way that
will allow anyone, whether
or not you consider yourself
creative or not to
be able to apply
these tools in different domains
of life-- work, family, play,
and on and on.
By the end of
today's episode, you
will have a better understanding
of what creativity is
and how to access it.
And if you like to bring others
into your creative endeavors
which as you'll soon
learn can massively
expand the extent to
which you yourself
can express your
creative talents.
As is the case with all episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
today we will discuss
both scientific mechanisms
and nomenclature.
And I promise to make
all of that clear to you
even if you don't have
a background in biology
or psychology.
But we will also, of
course, discuss tools.
That is, specific steps
that you can take in order
to be more creative.
One particular tool that I'm
excited to share with you
involves a meditation, but this
is a very unusual meditation.
This is not sitting with eyes
closed focusing on your breath
or focusing on a chime
or some other feature
in your sensory environment
or even in your body.
Later we will talk about
open monitoring meditations.
Open monitoring meditations are
very distinct from other forms
of meditation and
involve learning
how to sit back
and simply observe
your thoughts
while intentionally
varying where your thoughts go.
So for those of you
that find it a struggle
to focus or to refocus in more
traditional forms of meditation
or maybe even in your work
and even for those of you that
may suffer from things
like ADHD or similar,
open monitoring meditation can
be an extremely valuable tool
for accessing your
creative abilities.
Because of the
ways that it allows
you to tap into
specific circuits
within the frontal
networks of your brain,
so these are networks
of the brain that
include the areas just
behind your forehead
and that allow you to evaluate
new and novel rule sets
in a very unconstrained way.
Because if you think
about it, creativity
is really the ability to
take existing elements
from the physical world or from
the thought world, if you will,
or from any domain of life,
mood, thinking, and information
and to reorder those into
novel combinations that
are useful for something.
And as we'll also
find out later,
creativity has this
incredible aspect to it,
which is that when we see or
create or experience something
that is truly creative,
it reveals to us something
fundamental about the way
that the natural world
and indeed the way
that our brains work.
If that sounds very mysterious
and abstract to you now,
I promise that by the
end of today's episode,
you will not only
understand what that means
but you will also understand
how to use open monitoring
meditations as well as other
forms of tools in order
to access your creative ability.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is however part of
my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses
and sunglasses
that are the absolute
highest quality.
The company was founded by
two All-American swimmers
from Stanford and everything
about ROKA eyeglasses
and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind.
I've spent a lifetime
working on the biology
of the visual system.
And I can tell you that
your visual system has
to contend with an enormous
number of challenges for you
to be able to see clearly.
For instance, when you move from
a shady area to a sunny area.
There are all
adaptations that have
to occur in your eye and brain.
ROKA understands
these adaptations.
And the other ones
required to see clearly.
And those are built into the
engineering of their sunglasses
and eyeglasses.
One of the things that makes
ROKA eyeglasses in sunglasses
so terrific, is that they
are extremely lightweight.
In fact, most of the
time I don't even
realize that they're on my face.
I wear sunglasses when
I drive and whenever
I need to throughout the day
and I wear readers at night.
I do not wear sunglasses when I
get my morning sunlight, which
I do every single morning
as you should be doing also
as is covered many
times on this podcast.
ROKA eyeglasses and sunglasses
are also unique in that
unlike a lot of so-called
performance eyeglasses
out there.
They don't make you
look like a cyborg.
They have some of
the styles that
make you look like a cyborg,
if that's your thing.
But if you want to wear
glasses or sunglasses out
to dinner or around
for social reasons,
they have many different
aesthetic styles
to choose from.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses or sunglasses,
go to roka.com, that's R-O-K-A
.com and enter the code
Huberman to save
20% off your order.
Again, that's ROKA, roka.com
and enter the code Huberman
at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
And as you may have
heard me say before,
I am not a fan of
the word nootropics
because it means smart drugs.
And frankly, there
is no neural circuit
in the brain for being
quote unquote "smart."
There are neural
circuits for focus.
There are neural circuits
for task switching.
for today's topic,
which is creativity.
Nootropics therefore
is not a great word
to describe any
supplement or drug that
can enhance brain function
because it lacks specificity.
Thesis understands
this and therefore has
designed custom nootropics
that are tailored
to your specific needs and that
allow you to enter the brain
and bodily states that are
optimal for things like focus,
energy, creativity, and so on.
If you'd like to try your own
personalized nootropic starter
kit, go online to take
thesis.com/Huberman.
Take their brief
three minute quiz.
And Thesis will send you
four different formulas
to try in your first month.
Again, that's take
thesis.com/huberman and use
the code Huberman at checkout
for 10% off your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by LMNT.
LMNT is an
electrolyte drink that
contains everything you need
that is sodium, magnesium,
and potassium in
the precise ratios
that you need without sugar.
As I talked about many
times before on this podcast
and elsewhere, every
cell in your body
requires hydration
and electrolytes
in order to function properly.
And a key example of this are
the neurons, the nerve cells
of your brain that allow
you to think clearly,
to exercise hard, et cetera.
Neurons require sodium
in order to fire
what are called
action potentials
or electrical signaling
between neurons.
And they require
potassium and magnesium.
And those have to be present
in the correct ratios in order
for your brain and body
to function optimally.
LMNT is formulated
to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs.
And is perfectly suited
to anyone following
a ketogenic, low carbohydrate,
or Paleolithic diet,
or a basic omnivore diet which
is the one that I follow.
If you'd like to try LMNT,
you can go to drink element
that's lmnt.com/huberman to
claim a free element sample
pack with your purchase.
And right now LMNT has
two special flavors
for the holidays--
chocolate caramel and mint
chocolate, which I should
mention taste especially good
if you actually heat it up.
So if you treat it
like a tea, it works.
Or if you drink it
cold it's delicious.
All the flavors of
LMNT I find delicious.
Again, you can go
to drink element,
that's lmnt.com/Huberman.
The Huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered
with Momentous supplements.
To find the supplements we
discuss on the Huberman Lab
podcast, you can go to
livemomentous spelled
O-U-S, livemomentous/huberman.
And I should just
mention that the Library
of those supplements is
constantly expanding.
Again, that's
livemomentous.com/huberman.
Let's talk about creativity.
Now on the face of it, the word
creativity and creative acts
might seem somewhat
abstract to us.
That is, we know
when we see something
that we consider creative and
we know when we see something
that is not creative.
Things that aren't
creative are things
that we see every day, a car
with four tires, for instance,
a bicycle with two
tires, not creative.
However, we also see things that
are novel that are different
and that we don't really
think of as creative.
In fact, they can be
downright trivial.
For instance, if I were
to take a fish tank
and put wings on it,
that's a novel combination
of things, which is
one of the key criteria
for an act or an object
or a piece of music
that is creative.
And yet, neither of
us I believe would
find it very creative
or very interesting
that a fish tank
has wings on it.
Why or why not I should say?
Well, it turns out
that for something
to be creative it actually
has to reveal to us something
fundamental about the
world or about how we work.
And I must say that oftentimes
the most creative and the most
interesting and the most
beloved creative acts
reveal to us something
fundamental about the world
or the way that we work in a
way that delights and thrills
and surprise prizes us but
that we aren't even aware what
that fundamental rule is.
I'll return to this
in a few minutes.
But for the time being,
let's just build up
from first principles what
constitutes something creative
and what does not constitute
something creative.
Creativity is a way of
interacting with the world
or combining or recombining
things in the world
in a way that appears novel
to us and to other people.
My example of a fish tank
with wings on it is novel.
But frankly, it's
not very creative
and it's not very interesting.
It doesn't reveal
anything new to us.
Sure there are flying fish
although they just jump far,
they don't really fly.
And as a consequence,
putting wings on a fish tank
could be used as a metaphor for
the fact that fish don't fly.
But you already
knew and I already
knew that fish don't fly.
And so there's
nothing novel revealed
to us about the world except
something we already knew.
Now, creative acts on the
other hand, of course,
involve novel combinations
of existing rule sets that
could be different combinations
of music or colors or shapes
or technology, et cetera.
But it does so in a way
that tells us something
fundamental and different.
Let me give an example of a few
truly creative artistic acts.
And I'll do that in the domain
of visual arts but, of course,
there are many
examples that could
come from music or from other
domains sport, et cetera.
The examples I'll give rather
than a fish tank with wings
are for instance, the
comparison between a drawing
or a very accurate painting
of a face, an Escher
painting, and a Banksy.
If you don't know what
those are I'll explain.
First of all, let's talk about
an accurate representation
of a face.
If I were to sit
you down or if you
were to send me a
photograph and then
I were to paint
or draw a picture
of your face in a way that
faithfully represented,
the position and shape of your
nose relative to the eyes,
maybe a curl of the
lip, maybe a few hairs
of your eyebrows in a
particular way, that
really captured you accurately.
I think most people would
say, OK, it's accurate.
It looks a lot like the
photograph or the person.
And on the one hand why
that could be interesting
it's not particularly
creative because it faithfully
represents what's already there.
In contrast, a painting or
a picture like an Escher,
and for those of you that aren't
familiar with Escher's involves
a lot of repeating patterns.
So for instance, a bird image
that's repeated over and over
and over and over
again, sometimes
in partially overlapping manner.
And perhaps a building
that's repeated over and over
and over again or stones
repeated over and over again
or staircases over
and over again.
Escher's capture elements
from the outside world
and faithfully represent them,
but faithfully represent them
over and over and over again,
which is not typically seen
in the natural world.
In fact, most of what
our visual system does
is to eliminate repetitive
patterns when we see them.
In fact, most of what
our visual system does
is try and make us blind
to repetitive patterns
in our visual
environment and only
allow us to see things
that are unusual
in that visual environment.
Now, this is especially
true at visual scales.
What I mean by that is if
you were to go to the beach
and lie on your towel and
look down at the sand,
you would start to notice
that the sand is a very, very
repetitive pattern.
So at very small scales and in
particular at molecular scales
when you get down to the
level of atoms and so forth,
everything is repetitive.
It's the same thing,
is just reproduced
in different combinations
over and over again.
But as we move
through our world,
typically we're not looking
down at pebbles on the ground
or little grains of sand
or the pattern of leaves
in a particular clover or
something of that sort.
Most of the time
we're looking out
on landscapes or at
people's faces, et cetera.
And very seldom do we see
highly repetitive patterns
at that scale.
So what Escher's do
is they essentially
reveal to us a
fundamental feature
about the way that our
visual system works,
which is that repetitive
patterns tend to become noise
in our visual system.
That is, our brain encodes
repetition as things
not to be interested in.
And the things that stand
out against that repetition
as the things to be interested
in so-called signal to noise.
What Escher's do is they invert
the relationship between signal
and noise and they make the
repetitive patterns the signal
and the unusual
patterns the noise.
In fact, in every Escher
there are unusual patterns
and those completely
disappear to us.
Now, when you look at an
Escher, what you probably see
and what I see are just a bunch
of birds repeated over and over
again or buildings or staircases
repeated over and over again.
And you may like
Escher's and you may not,
that's not the point.
Today we're not
talking about taste
in particular creative acts.
What we're trying
to identify here
are the rules and mechanisms
of what constitutes something
creative and why it's creative.
And the key element here is that
what's revealed by an Escher
through these
repetition patterns
is an inversion of the way
that our brain normally
encodes visual images.
And therefore, the
rule that repetition
is suppressed in
our visual system
and that unusual visual features
are revealed to us, that rule
is what pops out to us
when we look at an Escher.
Now, when I say pops out I don't
mean that you look at an Escher
and go oh, normally I
don't see repetition,
normally I see the unusual
stuff, et cetera, et cetera.
But there seems to be something
about truly creative acts
that capture the attention.
And sometimes the delight
of many, many people
is that they reveal a
fundamental rule about how
the brain or the world works.
Let me give you a
different example
also from the visual art world.
Let me give you the
example of Banksy.
Banksy is an artist that many of
you are probably familiar with
and probably some of you
are not familiar with.
So for those of you that are
not familiar with Banksy,
Banksy is an artist
that most often
does two dimensional artwork.
So these would be stencils
or paintings or drawings
like many artists and does
them in an urban landscape,
an actual city or
suburban landscape.
That is, he draws or stencils or
graffiti in a very cryptic way,
I should say.
No one really knows who Banksy
is or when he does his art.
He just reveals his
art by putting it up.
But he does this in
the context of cities
and on three
dimensional objects.
So a good example would be he
will stencil next to a phone
booth a police officer.
Or he will graffiti next
to an actual fire hydrant
a dog lifting its leg to
urinate on that fire hydrant.
Now, what's interesting about
Banksy's is not simply the fact
that he puts two dimensional art
onto three dimensional surfaces
in the urban and
suburban landscape
because if you think
about it, that's been
done many, many times before.
All graffiti is that.
All City Art and murals is that.
So what's unique about Banksy?
What's unique about
Banksy or I should
say Banksy's, the actual
art, is that he combines
two dimensional art with a three
dimensional landscape in a way
that the concept
pops out at you.
What do I mean by that?
Well, in the case of
the dog lifting its leg
to urinate on the fire hydrant,
that's a scene that most people
and in fact, most children are
familiar with from cartoons
or from our basic understanding
of the stereotype of dogs
and I must tell you having
owned a male dog, a bulldog
Costello for many years.
Hydrants were a particular
target for Costello.
Of course, everything
was a particular target
for Costello urinating outdoors.
Nonetheless, he liked
to pee on fire hydrants.
That itself is not interesting.
Seeing a photograph of
a dog raising its leg
to pee on a fire hydrant
is not interesting.
Seeing a painting of
that isn't interesting.
Seeing an actual dog
urinating on a fire hydrant
isn't interesting.
In fact, seeing a painting in
two dimensions of a dog raising
its leg to, of course,
it can't actually
urinate but give you the
impression that it would
urinate on that fire
hydrant isn't particularly
interesting except for the fact
that it reveals to us something
fundamental, which
is that we tend
to pair visual relationships
between different objects
that share a common
theme and then
the theme tends to pop out us.
So, for instance,
the dog raising
its leg next to a
fire hydrant even
if the dog is drawn
in two dimensions
and the fire hydrant
is in three dimensions
allows the concept of
dog and fire hydrant
to emerge or pop out at us,
which reveals to us something
fundamental about
how our brain works,
which is that our brain encodes
concepts and entire stories
as symbols of interaction
between different objects.
Let me give you a
different example just
to make sure that
this hits home.
One of Banksy's more
famous paintings
is a rather politically
charged one,
which is of a girl holding
a bouquet of balloons.
And this two dimensional drawing
was put on to the West wall
dividing territories
in the Middle East.
A very controversial issue.
The controversies
of that issue are
not what I want to get into.
But I don't think
anyone would doubt
that is a controversial issue.
The two dimensional
drawing of the girl
with the balloons
on the actual wall
turns out to be quite
interesting as an art piece
because what it reveals to
us is the entire controversy
around the presence of
that wall and the desire
for certain people to breach
for other people to insist
that that wall not be breached
for whatever reason.
Again, this is not about
the particular controversy,
the point is that a two
dimensional image combined
with a three
dimensional structure
allows the purpose of that
three dimensional structure.
And the controversy around that
three dimensional structure
to pop out at us in a way that
if, for instance, we had just
seen a photograph of
somebody next to that wall
or with a ladder
or if we just seen
a drawing of a girl holding
a bouquet of balloons
on a drawing of that
wall to not emerge.
In other words, it captures
two fundamental features
of the visual system.
Our ability to encode
things in two dimensions
and understand symbols.
And our ability to understand
things in three dimensions.
And in particular, the wall
as a three dimensional object
is really interesting
because it's
an actual physical barrier.
So showing it as the
actual physical barrier
that it is in real space,
in three dimensions
turns out to allow the
interaction between those two
things.
The concept, the controversy
to pop out at us and make us
think about that particular
controversy and perhaps
where we each individually
stand on that controversy.
Now, there are many
examples of what I just
gave in the visual domain.
For instance, Rothko's
which are just
color on Canvas are
particularly interesting source
of information about the way
that the brain encodes color.
Later I'll fill in exactly
what that information is.
You may like
Rothko's, you may not.
But I'll tell you one thing.
When you look at
a Rothko, you are
seeing colors in a
very different way
than you would ever see
colors in any other context.
The fact that they don't
have a frame typically
and the fact that
there's no white canvas
allows the colors
that you see to be
novel hues of those
colors that you will not
see in any other context.
And in doing so
reveals to you what
your brain does in order to
understand and extract color.
Now in the context of
music, for instance,
you will sometimes hear a
street musician play a song
maybe a Bob Dylan song or a Led
Zeppelin song or a Pink Floyd
song pretty closely, pretty
accurately to the way
that song is played.
But, of course,
that's not creative.
That's just like the photograph
or the accurate portrait
of somebody's face.
Or you may hear an
acoustic version
of what's normally an electric
guitar song or electrical song
or vise versa.
Somewhat creative,
sometimes sounds
even better than the original
but not particularly creative.
However, each and
every one of us
has a particular taste in music.
Maybe it's classical, maybe
it's rock, maybe it's punk,
maybe it's hip hop.
Within each of those
genres, I think all of us
are familiar with hearing
something for the first time
and maybe even every time.
And there's something
about the combination
of the words and the
music or sometimes
just the music or just the words
that allows some feature of it
to pop out at us as
particularly exciting.
And when we feel that
excitement and we
feel that it's
really novel, it's
different than what we've
heard before, I assure you
what it's revealing
to you is the way
that your auditory
system and often
your auditory and
your emotional system
encodes information
that you hear.
And again, the rule
that it's revealing
is not splayed out for you.
For instance, it's
not told to you
oh, this is the way
you normally hear
and now you're hearing
things differently.
Sometimes it's the
change in for instance
in the way that
words are accented
or the way the sentences
are constructed.
This often you'll hear
in hip hop the way
that sentences are
constructed can be divided up
not as normal declarative
sentences the way
that they're typically written.
But the way that sentences
are chopped up and fractured
reveals to us new meaning
and in fact, enhanced
meaning about particular
words that we wouldn't
see if it was written
out as a paragraph
and then sung as a script that
would be the same as the one
that we would read.
Again, the point is that what
is exciting and novel to you is
just the way that you hear it.
But it's exciting
and novel to you
because there are circuits
within the brain that when
we hear or see or
feel or experience
known elements in new ways
that are truly creative,
the way that those neural
circuits function is changed.
And when neural
circuits change the way
that they function
simply by way of what
comes into our eyes,
our ears, and the way
that we experience
our feelings, there
is the release of
chemicals, including
the release of the
chemical dopamine
and other
neuromodulators as well
that make us feel both
surprised, delighted.
And this is very key,
excited in anticipation
that we might see it again.
So with the
understanding in mind
that true creativity
involves the l combination
of some elements could be notes
of music, could be numbers,
could be visual elements
like lines or colors,
could be physical
movements, et cetera.
But novel combinations
of some things
that reveal to us something
fundamental about the way
that our brain and/or
the world work.
And of course, as
I mentioned before,
that fundamental
thing may or may not
be consciously accessible to us.
We may not know what exactly
it is that's novel to us.
But it feels novel
and it feels true.
Well, with that
understanding in mind,
we therefore can ask,
what are the underlying
principles and
neural circuits that
underlie the creative process.
And the word process here
is especially important.
In fact, if there's
one thing I'd really
like to impress on
everybody is that when
thinking about biology,
it's almost always better
to think about verbs
as opposed to nouns.
So rather than
think of creativity
as a noun or somebody being
creative as an adjective,
think about the verb creativity.
That is what are
the steps required
and therefore what are the
cells and circuits and thoughts,
et cetera required in
order to be creative.
This element of
thinking about verbs
then allows us to say, OK, what
are the various steps in coming
up with a creative idea,
in testing a creative idea,
and then implementing
that creative idea.
And in doing so, we find based
on the scientific literature
that there are basically
three major networks
within the brain, each of
which is responsible for each
of the three steps to arrive
at something truly creative.
The first neural circuit
involved in creativity
is the so-called
executive network.
This is a goofy name because
the neural circuits that I'm
about to describe do a bunch
of other things as well,
but they certainly control what
are called executive functions.
Executive functions
are functions
that you and I both have,
which is our ability
to govern our thinking
and our behavior
in very deliberate ways.
And that is largely
accomplished through the use
of the neural circuitry
that sits right
behind the forebrain, the
so-called prefrontal cortex.
Now, the prefrontal
cortex involves
many different subregions.
It has a bunch of
different parts
just like any country has
different states, et cetera
and provinces.
Executive function involves
the prefrontal cortex
and some other
neural structures.
But for the sake
of this discussion,
executive function and
the prefrontal cortex
are mainly responsible
for suppressing action.
That is, for eliminating choices
among the infinite number
of choices that exist.
For instance, of what colors
to combine on a painting
or what lines to draw
or what notes to play
or what movements
to make in a sports
endeavor, what numbers to
include in a mathematics
endeavor, or what words
and letters and syllables
and sentences to include in
writing a creative passage.
The second network is the
so-called default mode network.
There's a lot of discussion
nowadays about the default mode
network as it relates to
consciousness and meditation,
et cetera.
The default mode network
does many different things.
But in the context of our
discussion about creativity,
the default mode
network is really
the network that
starts being engaged
when you close your eyes
and start paying attention
to what's going on in terms
of your thinking as opposed
to the sensory outside world.
And the default mode network is
especially important for what's
called spontaneous imagination.
Now, spontaneous
imagination is something
that you can try at any moment
if you were to close your eyes
and to try and not pay attention
to the sounds around you.
But even if you do, to just
pay attention to whatever
thoughts or feelings emerge
when your eyes are closed.
By closing your eyes
and shutting yourself
off to the outside
sensory world,
you start to engage much
more of your brain machinery
dedicated towards
what's going on
inside you, so-called
interoception but also
what you're thinking
about your thinking
whether or not your thoughts
are complete or incomplete,
whether or not they are
fragmentary in a way that goes
from one thought to another
distantly in the past
or present to future, et cetera.
Depending on time of
day, how well-rested
you are, how stressed you
are, how happy you are,
the default mode
network will take you
through a journey of
different types of thoughts,
different types of
feelings, et cetera.
The specific types of
thoughts and feelings
are not as interesting
as the fact
that when you close your
eyes you're essentially
engaging this default mode
network, which is essentially
the network associated with
imagination and imagination
based on elements that exist
only within your head, that
is within your brain and
therefore must rely on memory
of previous experiences.
As soon as you close your
eyes, you are shutting yourself
off from the sensory world.
So by definition
you can no longer
be bringing in novel
experiences in that moment.
You're relying on your library
of existing experiences
and your memory of those in
order to imagine new things.
And you're doing this in a
very free associative way.
You're not trying to
imagine new things.
It's just whatever
geysers to the surface.
So we've got the
executive network,
which is involved in suppressing
particular thoughts or actions.
We have the default
mode network, which
is involved in imagination.
And the default mode network
I should mention also
involves a subregion of
the prefrontal cortex.
It's called the medial
prefrontal cortex
but other brain regions as well.
And then the final
element within
the circuits
underlying creativity
is the so-called
salience network.
The salience network is a
network of brain regions
that involves areas such as
the Insula, which actually
has a complete map
of your body surface
as well as some
information mapped there
about what's going on
in the outside world
and how those
combined with what's
going on in your
internal landscape, that
is within your body.
Also a brain region called
the ACC or intengu--
excuse me, anterior cingulate
cortex and the amygdala.
So a lot of
information is mapped
within the salience
network about how we feel
and how we feel in relation
to things that are happening
around us and within us.
And the salience network
has one main job,
which is to pay
attention to what's
most interesting either
in the world or inside us
in terms of feelings
or experiences.
So we've got three networks--
executive network, which
is there to suppress
choices in terms of actions
we could take but
decide not to, or things
we could think about but
choose not to or try not to,
the default mode network,
which is basically the catalog
or library of
previous experiences
that we have available to us
that would act as the paints
on a palette or the
possible ingredients
that could go into a recipe.
All of that has to, again,
arise from previous experience.
We can't close our
eyes and suddenly
be able to access all the
melodies that we've never
heard before or all our ideas
and concepts and knowledge
about music if we don't
have musical understanding
or visual understanding.
So we're really
drawing up the library.
And that library tends to
be rather disorganized.
It swirls around.
It's not very structured
unless we're actively trying
to think about something.
And then we have the
salience network,
which is the networks within
the brain that decide or make
choices about what's most
interesting to pay attention to
in a given moment.
So those three networks work
together to create things.
And when I say create
things, we again
have to really
definition of creativity.
Creativity is a rearrangement
of existing elements into novel
combinations that reveal
something fundamental about how
we or the world works.
And, this is very important.
It tends to be things
that are useful.
Now, they can merely be
useful because they're
entertaining or
thrilling, they can also
have a particular utility
or use in the world
like a piece of technology
that is actually
useful like an app
or a smartphone
or a computer actually
has utility or a vehicle.
There are creative acts that
led to the formation of vehicles
and computers, et cetera.
But the point is that
just merely coming up
with novel combinations of
things like wings on a fish
tank, that's not
creative or it's not
creative in any meaningful way
because it's simply not useful.
It doesn't reveal anything
fundamental new or purposeful.
It doesn't allow
us to think about
or interact with the world
or ourselves in novel ways.
Whereas things, people,
actions, and ideas
that are truly creative
really change the way
that we are able to
access the world.
They act as portals to the
world and to ourselves.
I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors
Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greenes now called AG1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Greene since 2012.
So I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take Athletic Greens,
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets to me
the probiotics that I
need for gut health, our
gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics
and Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiome health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains a number
of adaptogens,
vitamins, and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met.
And it tastes great.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and they'll give you five
free travel packs that make it
really easy to mix up
Athletic Greens while
you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D-3 K-2.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year supply
of vitamin D-3 K-2.
So now you have some idea about
the brain areas and networks
involved in creativity.
But I want to be very
clear that any time we
talk about mechanisms
and brain areas, what's
far more important than the
names of those brain areas
is an understanding
of what they do.
So if you couldn't remember
the anterior cingulate
cortex or the fact that
the prefrontal cortex is
involved in executive function,
et cetera, that's fine.
It's less important that
you know the names of things
than you understand the action
steps that those things take.
That is the verb actions
that those particular brain
areas engage in order to arrive
at a particular endpoint.
And the endpoint we're talking
about today is creativity.
I want to discuss creativity
in terms of what actually
goes into being creative.
And it turns out there
are just two elements.
And those two
elements are now well
understood from the
perspective of psychology
and fortunately, the
neuroscience well
supports what the psychology
says and vise versa.
And those two elements
that go into coming up
with a creative idea and then
implementing or developing
that creative idea
into something real
that you and the rest of
the world can experience
or divergent thinking
and convergent thinking.
And divergent thinking
and convergent thinking
are very straightforward
to understand.
Divergent thinking is taking
some known object or event
in the world or
sport or concept.
It could be running.
It could be a musical note.
It could be jumping.
It could be a particular
color on a piece of paper.
And asking yourself how
many different things
could that thing actually be.
And you might say, well,
running is running.
But let's use divergent
thinking as a way
to illustrate what
divergent thinking is.
If I show you a picture
of somebody running,
I say, what do you.
See and you say I
see somebody running.
And then I might give you
a divergent thinking task
and these tasks
are the same ones
used in various experiments.
And I'd say, how many
different things can you
think about based on
this picture that you
see of somebody running.
Now, if you are able to
engage divergent thinking,
you could say
running to the store.
Running away from a lion.
Running towards somebody I love.
Or maybe you have a more
elaborate imagination
and you could say,
running in front of a bus
to grab a kid so the kid
doesn't get hit by the bus.
Or running toward a
concert because I'm
so excited about the
particular concert
and then it starts to
spool into a story.
In other words,
divergent thinking
involves taking one simple what
we would call a neuroscience
or psychology stimulus, one
image, or sound, et cetera
and trying to
radiate out from that
as many different divergent
situations, properties,
characteristics, events, things
from that one specific element.
So any divergent thinking task
would involve exactly that.
I'd show you pictures or play
you sounds or words or notes
or describe to you
events in history
and try and see how many
things can radiate out
from that in to diverse,
diverse, even distant types
of concepts and pictures.
OK.
So that's divergent thinking.
Divergent thinking
is really the process
that underlies idea generation.
And the basis of
divergent thinking
is that more than
one idea is correct.
In fact, the more ideas that
you have about one thing,
the better your
divergent thinking.
So if I were to give you
three minutes to list off
all the things you can think
about related to this pen
that I'm holding up.
For those of you listening
I'm just holding up
a pen in front of me.
You just write them
out or say them out.
Over the next 3 minutes
that would be an example
of divergent thinking.
However, if you just said
black pen, red pen, white pen,
green pen, et cetera, that's
not very divergent thinking.
It's only divergent in the
context of color space.
And when I say space
that's just a nerd
speak for one particular
domain of thinking.
Whereas if you said
red pen, white pen,
essay pen in a door
to hold the door
open so that someone can
return to a building.
And you started spooling
off a story related to that
and why that was important,
well, there you go.
Divergent thinking is
essentially taking one element
and coming up with
many, many answers.
And in the context of
divergent thinking,
any answer goes, but
as we'll soon learn,
not every answer is
interesting and relevant
that is not every answer help
solve something or reveal
something fundamental
and therefore,
not every divergent
answer is truly creative.
The other aspect of
divergent thinking
that's really
important to understand
is that the selection criteria
are extremely vague and vast.
That is, there
are no constraints
on what you come up with.
So if I hold up this
pen and you say,
orangutan, that's a perfectly
valid divergent idea
from this pen because
you thought of it
and it's distantly related.
However, we have to
remember our earlier rule.
If black pen and orangutan are
not linked up in our brain,
in the observer's brain
in any meaningful way,
it's only interesting
to you because you
are the only one
that understands
the rule that underlies the link
between this pen and orangutan.
Whereas if you come up with
something different that
somehow tells me and
everybody else something
interesting about
pens or orangutans,
now that's a truly
creative idea.
I don't have such
an example in mind
but later I'll give
you some examples
of how you can actually
March down the path
of divergent thinking and
use that executive network
to suppress certain
options to cross off
certain answers because, again,
an answer is valid but not all
valid answers are
interesting or useful.
And you can cross
those off and arrive
at the most interesting
and truly creative answer.
A couple of more things
about divergent thinking.
Divergent thinking largely
taps into the networks
of the brain that are involved
in mental flexibility.
So this is a different aspect
of our prefrontal cortex, which
is not based on executive
function and our ability
to reduce options but rather
areas of the prefrontal cortex
that are available to
generate multiple options
and actually suppress context
to forget that pens are just
for writing, for
instance, and that pens
can do other things
like hold a door open.
It's really an
unusual use of a pen.
Again, none of these
examples that I'm giving
are particularly interesting.
They're just designed to get
you to understand the underlying
concept of divergent thinking.
And then the last
thing I'd like you
to know about divergent thinking
is that divergent thinking
involves a exploration.
It's a wandering through
of ideas that you already
had in your library, in
your memory banks about pens
and what pens
could be related to
and what pens ought
not to be related to.
So, again, what's really
important about creativity
is that there has to be the
basic building blocks already
existing within us.
This is why it's so
important to understand
that if you are somebody who
really seeks to be creative,
you really do need to
be somebody who forages
for information and structured
information in particular
if you are to be creative.
The architect
simply can't come up
with incredible drawings
or plans for buildings
without understanding how
buildings are put together
in the various rules
that govern buildings.
In other words, you
can't break rules
that you don't understand.
I think in movies,
especially, we
have this idea in mind
of this limitless concept
or that we have these hidden
geniuses that somehow have
access to all the math
knowledge without ever having
done any formal math.
Actually I was flying
back from Texas recently
and Good Will Hunting
was on somebody's screen.
I don't tend to watch
movies on the plane
very often, sometimes
but not often.
And I was remembering
in that movie,
you've got this math genius who
is a janitor at MIT, et cetera
and apparently just has
access to all this knowledge.
It's a wonderful concept.
A very, very I would say
even exceedingly rare thing
to occur in the world.
Sure there are people
who seem to have
a natural talent for mathematics
or for something else.
But this idea that
there are incredible
geniuses among us that
just spontaneously
have so much knowledge, that's
by far the exception rather
than the rule, of course, and
may not even actually exist.
I'm sure someone will put
it in the comments examples
where this actually exists.
More often than
not, what you find
is that people who have extreme
virtuosity in a given area
put many, many years
into developing
the basic substrates,
the basic building blocks
of whatever it is
their craft happens
to be where they
demonstrate virtuosity.
So this is very
important to understand.
Nonetheless, divergent thinking
is the critical element
for initiating the
creative process.
Again, thinking about
creativity as a verb.
And divergent thinking involves
taking some starting point,
in this case a pen,
and then radiating out
from that in a fairly
unconstrained what biologists
call a random walk just
wandering through your thought
space and memory
space about what
could be related to this pen.
Now, on the flip
side of creativity
is the implementation of
specific combinations of things
and testing those to see whether
or not they are interesting,
relevant, or delight
to us or other people
or scare us or other people
or thrill us or other people.
In other words, a testing
of whether or not there's
some fundamental rule to emerge.
Again, I'm going to repeat
this many, many times
throughout this
episode and I'm not
going to apologize for
that because I think
it's so important to understand
that creativity is not just
novel combinations.
They are novel
combinations of things that
reveal something fundamental.
And that often pop out
to us if not every time
certainly most of the time
that we see that thing.
It almost never
seems to be the case
that something truly creative
dulls in its expression.
And that's because what
it's repeating to us
over and over again is this
fundamental rule that normally
we can't see or
hear or experience
in the absence of
this creative act.
So the second part of creativity
where things are tested
and where truly creative
elements are discovered
is in convergent thinking.
And convergent thinking
is, as the name
suggests, just the opposite
of divergent thinking.
Convergent thinking
would be, for example,
if I give you an image or I
tell you the following things,
I say wing, water, an engine.
The concept that I
happen to have in mind
is that of a plane
that can land on water.
Most planes don't
land on water or not
intended to land on water.
One would hope that
their plane doesn't
land on water unless
it's a plane designed
to land on water.
But in this case, a plane
that can land on water
is one of the very few answers
that can combine wing, water,
and engine.
I'm sure there
are other answers,
there are other
convergent thinking modes
that can take you to an
answer that would be valid.
But there are not many.
And here what's
really most important
is that I'm not asking
you to spool out
or to radiate out from
these three things.
Rather, I'm asking you to
combine them in some way that
makes sense in the real world.
And indeed there are planes
that can land on water.
And wing water and
engine combined
within those things
they are fundamental
features, they are in
fact, necessary but not
sufficient for having a
plane that can land on water.
OK.
So that's just one example
of convergent thinking.
And a convergent
thinking task would
involve you being given
a list of two or three
or maybe even five
different things.
And then for each of
those two or three or five
different things,
as quickly as you
can to come up with
a single answer
that binds all of those
in a real world concept
that obey the laws of nature
or physics in some way.
For instance, you can just come
up with some answer that said,
a bird that swallowed
an engine and that
happens to be a sea bird.
You could come up with that,
but that actually is not
something that happens or
is that very typical at all.
And so it seems like a mishmash
of things that are really
just designed for you
to try and accomplish
an answer rather
than something real,
such as a plane
that lands on water.
OK.
The point here is that
divergent thinking
is one aspect of our
cognition, of our thinking.
And convergent thinking
is a very distinct aspect
of our cognition.
In fact, one of the
critical requirements
for convergent thinking is
also to access our memory banks
and our understanding
about the outside world
just as it were with
divergent thinking,
but it requires more focus
and more persistence.
In fact, if we were to
come up with a key rule
for divergent
thinking, it would be
you almost want to have just
enough focus to remember what
the initial object or
thing that was mentioned
was to keep that in mind
so that your answers don't
become completely random.
But the more distant and
everywhere in between that
you can generate
answers that is,
the things that are
very close to pens,
black pen, red pen
versus pen and doorstop,
pen acting as a doorstop.
Those are-- one is
very close, red pen is
very close to black pen,
doorstop is pretty far
from black pen.
So that's the idea.
Is that you want to explore and
undergo a range of exploration
of different ideas whereas
with convergent thinking,
you're really trying to
bind these things together.
And so the key element
for convergent thinking
is the aspect of
persistence and focus.
And that's why convergent
thinking in many ways
feels harder than
divergent thinking.
It feels like there's an answer.
And I want to get the answer
right and I can't solve it.
It's a puzzle and
it's a puzzle that
relies on very
distinct brain circuits
from divergent thinking.
Which brain circuits?
Well, that's what we're
going to describe next.
And again, this
is not just going
to be a list of different brain
circuits with different names
doing different things,
that wouldn't be useful
to you or to me.
Rather, what you're about to
learn is truly incredible.
What it is we're going to talk
about one single molecule--
dopamine, which is a
molecule most typically
associated with motivation
and desire and drive
and feelings of
pleasure in some cases.
But that actually resides
within four different networks
in the brain.
Today we're going to talk
about two of those networks.
And dopamine acting
in one network
directly underlies
divergent thinking.
Whereas dopamine in
another brain network
underlies convergent thinking.
And if at this point
in this episode
you're saying OK,
when am I going
to get the tools to
understand creativity
and how to be creative,
what I can assure
you is that if you understand
divergent thinking which
hopefully now you do, and you
can understand what convergent
thinking is, and
you can understand
that dopamine is responsible
for both divergent thinking
and convergent thinking but
through separate pathways.
Well, then if you can understand
how those two separate pathways
work and how to engage
them differentially,
therein lie the tools that you
can use both to explore ideas.
In other words, find what it
is that could be creative.
And then systematically
test each of those ideas
for what is truly creative.
That is what meets the
criteria for something
that is novel and truly
useful and informs us
about something that we've never
seen, heard, or felt before.
Let's just take a moment to talk
about the incredible molecule
that is dopamine.
Many people are familiar with
dopamine from the concept
of quote unquote
"dopamine hits," which
is popular language describing
the feeling of pleasure
that we get from pretty
much anything that we like
or that we continue to
engage in repeatedly.
So some people will talk
about the dopamine hit
that they get from
somebody attractive
that they like texting them back
or the dopamine hit that they
get from social media or
the dopamine hit that they
get from sugar or the dopamine
that they get from this
or from that.
To be honest, the
concept of dopamine hits
is not one that I favor because
in general, whenever people
talk about dopamine
hits, typically
they are talking
about activities
such as social media
for which dopamine
may be involved at some level.
But often it's the case
that the behavior associated
with that thing in
this case, social media
is more of the compulsive
nature rather than
an active seeking of something
with positive anticipation.
And that's really what
dopamine is about at least
in the context of one of its
major functions in the brain.
Dopamine is really about
motivation and desire
and movement.
And it makes sense why
motivation, desire,
and movement would be
linked up through a common,
in this case neuromodulator
or chemical like dopamine.
Because throughout
evolution if we
were excited for or motivated
to pursue something,
we had to move in order
to get it, to obtain it.
And in general, we
can frame dopamine
under the umbrella
of dopamine tends
to be involved in
neural circuits
in the brain that are involved
in processes that are taking us
beyond the confines of our skin.
That is, they motivate us
to go do something in terms
of action in the world.
Now, that statement might
seem distantly placed
from a discussion
about creativity,
but as we'll learn
a little bit later,
one of the most useful tools
for engaging creativity
and becoming more creative is
to think about action elements
within a narrative.
That is, things that we
and others can do in order
to discover new rules
through actual movement.
That's a little bit cryptic.
Forgive me.
But I promise I'll
return to it later
and I will make
it crystal clear.
There are four major circuits
in the brain that use dopamine.
Although I should mention,
there are additional circuits
as well.
In fact, your eye
even contains neurons
that release
dopamine that control
the sensitivity of your eye
at different times of day
to light, et cetera.
The four major
circuits in the brain
that utilize
dopamine however, are
used for four major purposes.
And I'll describe
what those are.
First of all is a
neural circuit that
uses dopamine among other
things but certainly relies
on dopamine in a critical way
to engage movement, including
eye movements.
And we will return
to eye movement
to why they're so important
for understanding creativity
and maybe even for generating
creativity a little bit later.
The name of the
circuit, again, is less
important than what it does.
But the name of this circuit
for those that want to know
is the so-called
nigrostriatal pathway.
The substantia nigra
is a brain area
that is very dark that
projects to an area
called the dorsal striatum.
It contains a bunch
of subregions.
So, again, for those of you that
really geek out on this stuff
great, you can learn these names
and retain them in your memory.
If you don't care about
names, don't worry about it,
just discard the names.
But areas of the brain like
the caudate and putamen
and the dorsal
striatum receive input
from the substantia nigra.
In neuroanatomy, when
we name something,
we say the origin of that thing
and where it connects through.
So nigrostriatal
tells you that there
is a connection between
the substantia nigra
because it came
first, nigrostriatal,
and then striatal
is where it ends up.
So nigrostriatal pathway is
involved in generating bodily
movements.
It's involved in eye movements.
And it is actually
a brain area that's
engaged when you
think about movement.
You can just have a story
in your mind about walking
or a story in your mind
about running or story
in your mind about driving.
This area is engaged.
Very interesting brain area.
So that's the first circuit.
Very important to understand.
And I'll tell you
right now, that
is the brain circuit
that is engaged when
you undergo divergent thinking.
Now, that itself
should be interesting.
Even if you don't remember
any of the names of the things
I just told you, that
you have a brain circuit
that even if you just
think about walking it
becomes more active.
And the dopamine is involved
in that brain activity.
And if you recall,
divergent thinking
involves taking a concept
as boring as a pen
and thinking about
other concepts that
could link up with that pen in
some way, logical or illogical.
The bridge could be completely
abstract and really fantastical
with a bunch of different
ideas in between.
A pen acting as a doorstop
because of some situation
where you need to run
down stairs in a fire
and get back upstairs
quickly to rescue
somebody, very divergent.
Or as divergent as
black pen to red pen.
But what's amazing is
that that same circuit
is the one that's involved
in generating and thinking
about physical movement.
That turns out to be vitally
important for tapping
into the creativity process.
So really frame that up in your
mind or commit it to memory.
Now, the second dopamine circuit
associated with creativity
is the one associated with
convergent thinking, which,
again, is the
thinking where there's
a specific correct answer.
It requires focus and
it requires persistence.
And the name of that
circuit, again, the name
isn't as important
as what it does.
But the name of that circuit
is the mesocortical pathway.
The mesocortical pathway
is involved in motivation
and it has an emotional
component too.
Now, it will become
clear in a few minutes
why that emotional
component is vital.
But this is a circuit
that originates
in a brain structure called the
lateral ventral tegmental area.
Again, a bunch of words you
can remember it if you want,
lateral ventral
tegmental area or you
can not worry about the name.
And it connects to
the prefrontal cortex,
that area just
behind the forehead.
And this mesocortical
area is involved
in motivation and emotion
and is critical for focus
and persistence.
It is distinct from
a very nearby area,
just sitting right next door
the so-called mesolimbic area,
which is involved in desire
and feelings of reward.
And this is the area that
is associated more typically
with addictive behaviors
or compulsive behaviors.
We're going to leave
out the discussion
about the mesolimbic
pathway for now
because it's not critical
to divergent or convergent
thinking and it's not critical
to the process of creativity
at least as far as we know.
But I mention it because it
is the third and the four
dopaminergic circuits.
And then the fourth
circuit certainly
one I've never talked about
before on this podcast, which
doesn't mean anything
except that we
haven't gotten to it yet,
is that tuberoinfundibular
pathway.
And that is the
pathway associated
with dopamine and
your pituitary gland
and the release of
hormones, in particular
that travel to the ovary.
If you have ovaries
or to your testes
if you have testes and
trigger the release of things
like estrogen and
testosterone, et cetera.
Dopamine is intimately
involved in that circuitry.
Again, not the topic
of today's discussion.
For today's discussion,
we want to remember
that there's a
dopamine circuit called
the nigrostriatal circuit,
which is involved in movement
and divergent thinking.
And that alone should set
a flag up for you like wow,
just thinking about
new ideas has something
to do with physical movement.
And the dopamine circuit that is
the mesocortical pathway, which
is the one that's associated
with motivation and emotion,
and that's the one required
for persistence and focus
for convergent thinking.
Why am I telling you all
of this about dopamine?
Well, it turns out that dopamine
creates a certain number
of responses in the brain and
body when it is active in one
or the other of these circuits.
And just for sake
of simplicity, so
I don't have to keep saying
nigrostriatal and mesocortical.
Here going forward,
I'm going to talk
about the dopamine
circuit that's
associated with
divergent thinking
or the dopamine
circuit associated
with convergent thinking.
And, again, divergent
thinking and convergent
think are the two processes
that have to occur.
Usually first divergent then
convergent thinking then
back and forth
and back and forth
in order to arrive at
something creative.
Divergent thinking
is about exploration.
Convergent thinking is about
testing things and coming up
with things that are the
right answer that feel right.
And we will better define what
right means a little bit later.
But you already know
right in this context
is when you have some
combination of elements
or some idea or
some written passage
or some music or
some physical action
that you just know this is
really novel and really cool.
Or people see it or
hear it or taste it
and say, this is really
novel and really cool
and they don't
necessarily know why.
It's just different in
a way that feels true.
I'd like to take a brief
break and thank our sponsor
InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to help you better
understand your body
and help you reach
your health goals.
I've long been a
believer in getting
regular blood work done.
For the simple reason
that many of the factors
that impact your immediate
and long term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
The problem with a lot
of blood and DNA tests
out there however,
is that you get data
back about metabolic factors,
lipids, and hormones,
and so forth.
But you don't know what
to do with those data.
InsideTracker
solves that problem.
And makes it very easy for you
to understand what nutritional,
behavioral, maybe even
supplementation based
interventions you might
want to take on in order
to adjust the numbers of
those metabolic factors,
hormones, lipids,
and other things that
impact your immediate and
long-term health to bring
those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate
and indeed optimal for you.
If you'd like to
try InsideTracker,
you can visit
insidetracker.com/huberman
and get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
That's
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
Now, I realize that for some of
you listening to this episode,
we are probably at the point
along the pathway of concept
and definition
and mechanism that
leaves you in a place
of real wanting a tool.
And so I promise that I'm
going to get into more tools,
but to satisfy you and to
make sure that you do indeed
understand that
there are tools that
can emerge from the information
that you already now
have in mind.
I do want to share with
you one particular tool
from the literature that
has been demonstrated over
and over again to support
and build and enhance
divergent thinking.
And I also want
to share with you
a tool that has been shown
from the scientific literature
to enhance convergent thinking
because both convergent and
divergent thinking are critical
for the creative process.
Now, I should emphasize
that some people out there
either by training or
by genetics or by both
will be naturally better
at divergent or convergent
thinking.
And in fact, we now know
in almost poetic way
that naturally
occurring variations
in genes which underlie
naturally occurring variations
in the percentage of
dopamine in one set of brain
circuits versus another do,
seem to relate to whether or not
people are naturally good
at divergent thinking
or convergent thinking.
Now, that's a very
nature based explanation
for why some people are
better at divergent thinking
and other people are better
at convergent thinking.
Nature and nurture is
something that can never really
be teased apart exactly because,
of course, if someone has
a natural proclivity for
something based on their genes,
you can't often separate
that from their parents
because we inherit our
genes from our parents
although even in cases
where people are raised away
from their parents through
adoption, et cetera.
It's very hard to separate
nature and nurture
because somebody with a
natural proclivity for things
might engage in those things
more, et cetera, et cetera.
The point is that
for those of you that
are very, very good
at divergent thinking
or very, very good at convergent
thinking, some of that
might have been inherited.
But more than likely some of
that depended on the activities
that you engaged in
in your early years,
in particular in the years
between age 5 and 25.
And for those of you that
are aged between 5 and 25,
all I can say is
please learn to engage
both divergent and convergent
thinking as much as
possible because you will
enhance your ability for both.
For those of you
25 and older, you
can still enhance
your ability to engage
divergent and
convergent thinking.
And the fortunate news,
the equalizer I should say
is that regardless
of whether or not
you're a naturally better
at divergent or convergent
thinking or you acquired
it through activities,
you need both in
order to be creative.
So what we know is that in order
to engage divergent thinking,
we need access to
our memory banks.
We need to come up
with possibilities.
And those possibilities
can only come
from what's contained within
our memory systems of our brain.
Areas like the
hippocampus, et cetera.
But the names
again don't matter.
We just know that
if we are going
to come up with novel
combinations of things or novel
uses of things or totally
new ideas about how
objects or notes of
music or foods or tastes
or whatever can be
combined, we have
to do that with
pre-existing knowledge.
And yet what we
need to do in order
to engage divergent
thinking is suppress
what is called
autobiographical narratives
and in particular,
autobiographical narratives.
We need to discard
with judgments
about how certain
combinations of things
impacted us in the past.
This here I think
is what people mean
when they encourage the
exploration of creativity
by so-called
boundary exploration.
You hear about this a
lot in the self-help,
in psychology literature.
And I'm not at all
disparaging of that literature
although rarely does it define
exactly how and why to go
about being more
creative or in this case
to be more divergent
in our thinking.
So they'll say, you
have to take risks
or you have to
suppress judgment.
But how do you actually do that?
Well, there's a wonderful
paper that talks about one way
to do it.
One way to do it is what's
called open monitoring
meditation or even just
open monitoring thinking.
And just to make
what could otherwise
be a somewhat complex
section here very simple.
What I'll also tell
you is that if you
want to enhance
convergent thinking,
you can do that
a number of ways,
but you can do that
in particular by doing
a different type of meditation
or thought process, which
is called focused
attention meditation.
So let's talk about open
monitoring meditation
and why it's so
useful for enhancing
divergent thinking,
this critical element
of the creative process.
First of all, open
monitoring meditation
and focused attention
meditation can be performed
the exact same way physically.
You can sit there,
eyes closed, I
don't care if you're
in a Lotus position,
it doesn't really matter, you're
lying down, you're standing up.
You could in theory do open
monitoring meditation with eyes
open and that would be an
interesting variant on it.
But for sake of the
discussion right
now, let's just
focus on the study
that talks about these
specific tools and the way
that they were
used in the study.
The title of the paper that
I'm essentially summarizing
is called open monitoring
meditation reduces
the involvement of brain regions
related to memory function.
Now, right off the
bat that will cue you
to something interesting.
Something about divergent
thinking and open monitoring
is related to
suppressing memory.
But as you recall,
just a few moments ago,
I said that in order to
engage in divergent thinking,
you need to kill off
the narratives of what
has to be related to what and
come up with new narratives.
You still need to
understand possibilities
but you need to forget
prior understanding of what
those possibilities have to be
and start thinking about what
those possibilities could be.
And so that it turns
out involves suppression
of certain brain areas.
Open monitoring
meditation is typically
done for about 10 to 30 minutes
although it could be longer.
And unlike other
forms of meditation
where you sit and
concentrate on your breathing
and trying to redirect your
thinking back to your breathing
or to your posture or
to a chant or a mantra,
open monitoring
meditation is simply
a matter of having sit there
or lie down and close your eyes
and to allow whatever surfaces
in your mind to surface.
And what you practice is
the practice of nonjudgment.
Now, nonjudgment itself is a
little bit of an abstract theme
because, of course, the
moment you say don't judge you
and others start to judge.
It's just the way
that the brain works.
You say, don't think
about an elephant
you think about an elephant.
That's a perfectly natural.
You go to an edge of a bridge
or a cliff and you think about
jumping off even
though you don't.
Please don't jump off.
And that's because it's
part of the circuitry that's
keeping you from jumping off.
Is the thought about what
would happen if you did.
OK?
So open monitoring
meditation involves
dedicating a certain amount of
time where you close your eyes
and whatever thoughts arise,
whatever emotions arise,
whatever ideas arise
to watch those and take
an inventory of them to just
merely watch them show up
and pass or maybe become fixated
on them for some period of time
or maybe even just one
for a long period of time.
All of that is fine.
In other words, whatever
surfaces surfaces.
That's open
monitoring meditation.
And that we know from
brain imaging studies
and we know from
measurements of dopamine,
in particular brain circuits and
we know from people who train
with open monitoring
meditation on a regular basis
improves divergent
thinking capability.
So in terms of tools, practicing
open monitoring meditation
or what I would just call
open monitoring thinking
is going to be immensely useful.
And this is actually
an opportunity
to queue up something that
I mentioned in our episode
on meditation, which goes deep
into the different meditation
involving focus inward
and outward, et cetera.
You're welcome to
check out that episode.
It's at hubermanlab.com.
But the point is that rather
than think about the word
meditation, which carries a
bunch of ideas about what it is
and what it isn't
and how to do it,
meditation is really just
a perceptual exercise.
For instance, you
could do a meditation
where you look at a single
point on a wall for five minutes
and redirect your focus to that
single point on a wall over
and over again
every time your mind
drifts as it no doubt would.
Or to a tone in the room.
You could attend to that
and redirect to that.
Rather than think about
it as a meditation,
it's really just a
perceptual exercise.
That's all that meditation is.
So open monitoring
meditation is really
just a form of perception
where you're paying attention,
you're perceiving your thoughts
without laying judgment
to those thoughts or
trying not to lay judgment
to those thoughts.
And what people
find is that they
very quickly within
a few days get better
at doing open
monitoring meditation.
And fortunately,
within just a few days
and certainly within about a
week or more of practice and it
doesn't even have to
be daily practice.
So although, of
course, daily practice
will accelerate the
process further,
people become significantly
better at divergent thinking.
And that's because of
the dopamine circuits
and in particular, along
the nigrostriatal pathway
becoming more active.
And the wonderful
thing is that when
you repeat a practice and
a particular neural circuit
is engaged over and
over again deliberately,
that neural circuit
becomes easier to engage.
So-called neuroplasticity.
So I would encourage
any of you that
want to explore the creative
process for whatever reason
or get better the
creative process,
dedicate some amount of time.
Maybe even just five
minutes every other day
to doing this open
monitoring meditation.
I've tried this meditation.
It's actually quite fun to
do because at least to me
it feels a lot easier than
the meditation associated
with convergent thinking.
Now, the convergent
thinking meditation
is the so-called focus
attention meditation.
And that's also described
in the same study.
And other studies have
explored which particular brain
networks it involves.
And I can just tell
you that focused
attention meditation,
which you can think of
or I'd prefer that you think of
just as a perceptual exercise
involves sitting or lying
down, closing your eyes,
focusing either on your breath,
or some element of your body.
Could be the tops of your knees
or the clasp of your hands.
It could be focusing
on an auditory tone,
you could even do it eyes open
and stare at a point on a wall
or a flame of light.
Whatever it happens
to be that allows
you to redirect your focus to
a particular location or idea
or sound.
That is known to
improve your ability
to engage convergent
thinking, to quickly
parse through or analyze a
bunch of different choices,
and to persist in
choice selection
and therefore more rapidly
arrive at the correct answer.
This is well-established
and, in fact, in, the episode
I did with a wonderful
guest Dr. Wendy Suzuki
from New York
University she talked
about how a daily meditation
of about 10 to 13 minutes
performed for about eight weeks.
That's what they explore.
And that study greatly
increases people's ability
to focus and in
fact, their memory.
And that's exactly
the point, which
is that convergent thinking as
I mentioned before, it requires
persistence, focus, and
access to specific memories.
So if you are somebody who
wants to get better at focusing,
that is the meditation for you.
However, because today we're
talking about creativity,
if you are somebody
who wants to get better
at divergent thinking
and convergent thinking,
the two elements of creativity.
That is, I would encourage
you to do a dual meditation.
That is, a meditation
that starts
with open monitoring for
maybe 5 to 10 minutes
and then transitions to
focused attention for maybe
5 to 10 minutes.
Because the positioning
of divergent thinking
and then convergent thinking
close together, more closely
resembles what the
creative process really is
and what it typically involves.
Most of us would love to
have a situation where
we can spend a morning or a
day or a week brainstorming.
Just brainstorming.
Whatever we think about is fine.
That's divergent thinking.
Whatever elements just throw
them up on the whiteboard.
We sometimes see
people and companies
doing this at retreats.
You bring people into
a novel environment.
You say, let's just
forget all the rules
and let's just come up with
new ideas about something.
New uses of something,
new strategies.
And nothing is too crazy.
Nothing is off limits.
And sure, that's
a useful exercise
so-called brainstorming.
But at some point,
there's the requirement
to cross off things.
And typically that's
done later in the retreat
or later in the meeting
or later in the weekend.
And that's a wonderful
way to approach creativity
and to try and be creative.
But not a lot of people train
for that on a regular basis.
So what I just
described to you are
research tested
tools for training
for divergent thinking
and convergent thinking.
And I would encourage
people who are
interested in being more
creative to try and do these
on a somewhat regular basis.
If not every day then certainly
a few times a week or more.
Certainly the more
you do it, the better
you're going to get it.
That's well demonstrated
in the literature.
And if you're somebody
who's very consistent doing
maybe five minutes of open
monitoring meditation and five
minutes immediately
after of focus attention
meditation daily, you
can expect that you
will get very, very good
at these processes very,
very quickly.
Now, I'm not going to go
into a lengthy description
of the different lines of
evidence that the corresponding
areas of the brain are active
in each of these different .
Meditation but
what I can tell you
is that there have been
some beautiful what
are called loss of
function studies
where particular brain areas
are either depleted of dopamine
or where dopamine
in some cases I
guess what we would call
gain of function studies
although not the gain
of function studies
associated with virology
different gain of function
studies where you enhance the
level of dopamine in the brain.
What you find is that both
divergent and convergent
thinking are enhanced
when levels of dopamine
are elevated.
Now, we're not necessarily
talking about pharmacology
here.
It turns out that
there are other ways
to elevate dopamine
that make us better
at divergent and convergent
thinking in particular,
by using mood.
And now I'd like to
talk about what mood you
are in when you happen to
start a creative process,
or try and do a training such
as open monitoring meditation
or focused meditation.
How your mood relates to your
level of dopamine at baseline.
What we call your
tonic as it's called,
meaning consistent or
ongoing level of dopamine,
how that dictates whether or
not you are going to be better
at one particular aspect of
the creative process or another
and how you can enhance
your creativity in the very
short term, very quickly using
tools that are known to trigger
additional release of dopamine,
which in some cases is good
and in some cases is
bad, I should mention.
And in other words,
determine how
you feel in one
moment should dictate
what tool you should use in
order to become more creative.
The relationship between
mood and creativity
is a fascinating
one that is bridged
by one main feature, which is
the amount of dopamine present
in this nigrostriatal pathway.
And there's a really
wonderful correlate
or measure of the
amount of dopamine
that's active in
that pathway that
can be addressed noninvasively
in the laboratory.
As I mentioned, the
nigrostriatal pathway
is involved in movement
and in eye blinking which,
of course, is a movement.
It's not a movement of
the sort that we typically
think of when we
think of movements,
but nonetheless it
relies on dopamine levels
in this pathway.
And in fact, we can
state very confidently
that when dopamine
levels are elevated,
the blinking reflex
is more active.
People just blink more.
When dopamine levels are lower
or less active in this pathway,
people tend to blink less.
So blink frequency
is a common measure
in studies of dopamine
within this pathway that
relate to creativity.
The work that I'm
about to describe
is largely the
work of two authors
who have done wonderful
work across several papers.
Unfortunately,
for me their names
are difficult to pronounce.
So I apologize to them
and their relatives
for what is sure to be
incorrect pronunciation.
But the last names
of these authors
are Chermahini and Hommel.
They're in the Netherlands.
So Chermahini and Hommel done
a number of different papers
or studies rather
of the relationship
between blinking,
mood, and creativity
in particular,
divergent thinking.
What they found is that
if people are blinking
fairly often and they
measure their mood
through subjective
tests and if they
were to do brain imaging,
which other studies have done,
they find is that
those people can
engage in divergent
thinking very easily.
In other words,
being in a good mood
facilitates divergent thinking.
Now, some of you might
immediately say, well, duh,
if you're in a good
mood you can be
more playful about the
exploration about what
could happen with
these notes of music
or these foods, et cetera.
But it's not so obvious.
Because it turns out that if
your dopamine levels are very,
very high, and this can
be measured noninvasively
through the frequency
of blinks or it
can be measured more invasively
through brain imaging
even through blood
draws or other methods
to measure dopamine.
If dopamine levels are very,
very high, what you observe
is that divergent thinking
is actually very, very poor.
Now, a naturally occurring
truly pathological example,
this would be something
like manic bipolar disorder
where somebody is in the
manic phase or somebody who
has taken methamphetamine or
cocaine, what tends to happen
is that they have lots and lots
of ideas, all of those ideas
seem really exciting to them.
But if you were to talk to
them for any given moment,
they would be very fixated on
one particular tunnel of ideas.
And by being fixated on one
particular tunnel of ideas
like the idea that they're going
to run for president tomorrow,
this is unfortunately
typical of people
who have bipolar, which is
not to say that everybody who
runs for president is bipolar
rather people who are bipolar
often have these
delusions of grandeur
that they're somehow going
to be president simply
because they decided to and that
they were selected to do this,
et cetera, et cetera.
Ideas about themselves
and other people
that are very constrained.
In other words,
not very divergent.
So divergent thinking is favored
by having elevated levels
of dopamine but not too high.
Well, that, of course,
creates a conundrum.
How do you know how
much dopamine you need
and how to achieve those
elevated levels of dopamine.
Well, leaving aside
people who are suffering
from a manic episode what
Chermahini and Hommel have
discovered is that if
people are in a low mood,
they're not feeling great,
maybe they're depressed
but they're just not
feeling that great.
They feel on a scale of 1 to 10,
around a 2, or a 3, maybe a 4.
The probability
that they will be
able to engage effectively
in divergent thinking
is quite low.
However, the good news
is, they are typically
very susceptible to
elevations in mood
through observing or
hearing positive stories,
listening to music
that they like,
any kind of so-called
inspirational stimuli.
Now, this is good news.
What this means
is that if you're
somebody who's not feeling
very motivated to engage
in divergent thinking, you're
not feeling very creative,
you're feeling a little low.
The thing to do in
that case is actually
to take external stimuli.
Things that you like and start
interacting with those stimuli
to get your mood elevated
and then to engage
in divergent thinking.
However, what Chermahini
and Hommel have also shown
is that if people are
already in a very good mood,
elevating dopamine
further is not conducive.
And in fact, is detrimental
to divergent thinking.
And in that case, they would
be better off for example,
not engaging in any
activities or taking anything
in the way of pharmacology
that would further
increase their dopamine.
And probably limiting the
amount of external stimuli
that are coming in through
music and visual stimuli
and really focusing
on divergent thinking
and the creative
process immediately.
Now, this is important.
In an earlier episode
both on bipolar
and on other forms
of depression,
I talked about how rates
of bipolar manic episodes
and dopamine levels
and creativity
tend to be correlated.
Now, unfortunately, rates of
suicide are 20 to 30 times
higher in people who have
bipolar disorder as well.
And so there's a whole dark
side to the bipolar disorder
that makes it a very, very
dangerous and important
disorder to treat.
But for sake of the
discussion of creativity,
what this means is
that we all need
to develop some
intuitive sense as to
whether or not our mood is--
suppose we could spin this into
three categories is kind of--
yes, happy, excited, positive
mood, and, of course,
there are going to
be levels to that.
Low like, mmmh, or
meh in the middle.
So if you're in a
low mood or meh mood,
by all means engage
in something probably
for about 5 to 30
minutes that elevates
your mood before trying to
engage in divergent thinking.
However, if you happen to be
in a pretty positive mood,
even if you're not 10
out of 10 on mood, then
bringing in additional
stimuli to increase
your levels of dopamine
will not help you
and in fact can hurt the
divergent thinking process.
So in that case, I
would also encourage
you to think about
something that
was discussed on a
previous episode, which
is the particular
effects of caffeine.
I'll get into caffeine
a little bit later.
But just very briefly,
caffeine increases
levels of dopamine receptors.
So it's not the caffeine is bad.
In fact, caffeine can
be neuroprotective,
it can enhance
focus and so forth.
But divergent thinking
is anti focus.
It requires just
enough focus to be
able to come up with new ideas.
But you actually don't
want to be overly focused.
Focus is more conducive
to convergent thinking.
In fact, that's exactly
what the literature
shows, is that caffeine because
its effects on epinephrine
and related systems in
the brain like adenosine.
But mainly because
of its effects
on persistence and
focus is very conducive
to convergent thinking.
So if you're somebody who
wants to explore creativity
and wants to get
better at creativity,
you now know that
you need to engage
in divergent thinking and then
afterwards convergent thinking.
I would recommend not using
stimulants such as caffeine
prior to divergent thinking
but rather use stimulants
if you do want to use
stimulants such as caffeine
prior to convergent thinking.
And in fact, in formulating
the architecture
of today's episode,
which took me
many hours across many
different days I confess,
I actually decided to try this.
In trying to imagine the
different configurations
and ways that this
information can be organized,
I deliberately
abstained from caffeine
during those bouts of work.
And when structuring
everything according
to the decisions I
had already made,
I purposely ingested
caffeine prior to that.
Now, of course, constructing
a podcast episode
is not really the ultimate
example of a creative act
because, of course, it's
taking existing information.
It's arranging in a novel ways.
But it doesn't necessarily
allow key concepts
to pop out in the way
that, for instance,
Banksy or a Rothko or
an Escher would pop out.
I'm certainly not naive
in thinking that it does.
But the principle of is
what's important here.
You need divergent thinking.
You need convergent thinking.
You need some level
of elevated dopamine
in order to engage in
divergent thinking.
But not so high that it starts
to inhibit that process.
Now, if you were to come
into the laboratory,
this could be measured by
your frequency of blinking.
For better or for
worse, we can't actually
count the number of times that
we blink unless we're actively
paying attention to it.
So I don't recommend that you
pay attention to your blinking
because that will take
you off course from all
the other important
things of your life.
And how many times
you're blinking
is rarely an important thing
for you to pay attention to.
You can however, learn to
calibrate your mood that is,
to assess your mood whether
or not you're in low, medium,
or high mood.
No problem using
that broad binning.
You could scale it on 1 to 10.
And then decide
whether or not you're
going to use some
dopamine elevating
stimulus from the outside.
Again, could be music, could be
exercise, is an excellent way
to elevate dopamine.
I'll talk about another
well-established one
from the research
literature that
is known to elevate dopamine by
65% in the particular pathway
that's relevant for
divergent thinking
and to do that without
any pharmacology.
I'll share that with
you in a moment.
But you need to decide
for you in a given moment
or in a given work attempt
at creativity what you need
and apply accordingly.
Because as Chermahini and Hommel
have shown, whether or not
you are in a low mood,
medium mood, or high mood,
really can determine
whether or not
you'll be able to access
divergent thinking or not.
Now, if you're somebody who
already has an idea in mind,
you're very excited
about a creative idea
and you want to hone it,
you want to shape it,
you want to pressure test it.
We'll talk a little
bit more about what
that means in a three step
process in just a little bit.
I would strongly
encourage you to look
at that process is a very
linear process in which there
are right and wrong answers.
And there, the use of caffeine
at appropriate dosages
and dosages for
caffeine that are safe
and in fact,
performance enhancing
were covered in the
episode on caffeine turns
out it's 1 to 3 milligrams
per kilogram of body weight,
by the way.
And if you want to
leverage caffeine or maybe
even other forms of
healthy legal stimulants,
those are covered in
the caffeine episode.
And I'll talk about a few
more a little bit later.
So to summarize this
segment and also
just to make a
more general point,
I think it's very
useful for people
to start to pay attention to
what their tonic level, that
is their baseline
level of dopamine
ought to be in this
nigrostriatal circuit
and in other circuits.
And to do that by learning
to assess one's mood
and pay attention to what
mood they happen to be in.
And then to leverage tools.
Behavioral tools, maybe
pharmacologic tools
provided they're safe
and they're legal
in order to either
increase dopamine
or to elect not to
increase dopamine in order
to access the creative process.
Now, I've mentioned
pharmacology a few times.
And I'd like to talk about
that just a little bit more
in the context of dopamine.
First of all, there is
no supplement or drug
that you or anyone else can
take that will selectively
elevate dopamine in only
one of the four circuits
that I described before.
This is just the state of
the technology nowadays.
If you take a pill
or even if you
were to inject some
substance, again, I
hope this would be legal
and safe, et cetera.
Whatever mode of delivery,
there is no technology
that exists at this time that
would allow you to selectively
amplify dopamine.
For instance, just in the
nigrostriatal pathway or just
in the means of
mesocortical pathway.
Again, the nigrostriatal
pathway associated
with diversion thinking, the
music mesocortical pathway
associated with cognitive
persistence and convergent
thinking.
If you were to amplify
dopamine levels, for instance,
by taking the amino
acid precursor
to dopamine
L-Tyrosine, something
that I occasionally
do to enhance
dopamine levels for
sake of work or energy,
500 milligrams or 1,000
milligrams even of L-Tyrosine.
Sometimes I'll combine that with
other things like Alpha-GPC.
It's going to enhance
dopamine transmission
in the nigrostriatal pathway,
the mesocortical pathway,
but also in the
mesolimbic pathway,
and also, for that matter in
the tuberoinfundibular pathway
associated with the pituitary.
There is no way to direct
dopamine activation
to just one of those pathways.
That's just a reflection
of the existing technology.
Now, this is also true if
you rely on illicit drugs
to increase dopamine.
So if it's cocaine
or methamphetamine,
those will greatly increase
dopamine but nonselectively
across all those
different pathways.
And likewise with any drugs that
inhibit or block or antagonize
as it's called dopamine.
This is why people who, for
instance, have schizophrenia
and take drugs to suppress
auditory hallucinations, some
of those drugs work because they
block the so-called D2 receptor
of the dopamine pathway.
D2 receptors are
present in all four
of the dopaminergic
pathways in the brain.
And oftentimes, those
drugs will in fact
suppress psychotic symptoms,
auditory hallucinations,
et cetera, because
they reduce dopamine.
But those people oftentimes will
have problems with movement.
They will express what's called
in the clinical literature
tardive dyskinesia.
Writhing of the
face and the body
from suppression
of dopamine within
the nigrostriatal pathway, which
is associated with movement.
They will sometimes have
deficits in eye blinking.
People with Parkinson's
who actually
have selective deficits of
dopamine within the substantia
nigra.
Nigrostriatal, remember,
it's substantia nigra
show deficits in what?
In movement.
In the smoothness of movement.
Oftentimes they
won't blink at all.
They'll have a blank stare.
And they have other
issues as well.
So if you're somebody who
is interested in increasing
dopamine through the use
of legal safe pharmacology
as I would hope it
would be the case,
there are ways to
do that, reasonably
safely for most people.
Again, people with
bipolar disorder issues,
with the dopaminergic
pathway should not do this.
I know nowadays there's
a lot of use of drugs
that increase dopamine such as
Ritalin, Adderall, modafinil,
armodafinil, often prescribed
for things like attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder.
We did an entire episode
on ADHD and pharmacologic,
prescription, supplement, and
behavioral, nutritional tools
for ADHD.
You can find that episode
at hubermanlab.com.
I know a number of people
take those compounds in order
to increase dopamine and
focus for sake of studying
or other activities staying
up long hours, et cetera.
And the fact that
they increase focus,
they are effective although
they do have their side effects.
Sometimes severe, sometimes
habit forming, sometimes
even addicting as well.
But the fact that
they increase focus
should automatically
tell you something
that those drugs in
particular increase
dopamine in the
so-called mesocortical
and mesolimbic pathways.
Why can I say that?
How can I say that with
any degree of confidence?
Well, there are these four
pathways ones involved
in movement, but
these other ones
are involved in motivation
and desire and reward.
And I told you that
these things can
be habit forming and
addicting in some cases
and they are can
greatly increase focus.
And focus is supported by
enhanced levels of dopamine
within this mesolimbic
and mesocortical pathway.
So yes, those drugs increase
dopamine across the board,
but there does seem to be
some weighting of dopamine
toward the systems involved
in motivation and reward
and sometimes even leading to
habit formation and addiction.
That's why those
drugs should only
be taken with the close
supervision of a very
skilled psychiatrist or somebody
else who's board certified
who can really govern that.
There are however, ways
to increase dopamine
more evenly across the
board using nonprescription
approaches.
And one I already
mentioned, which
is L-Tyrosine taken
typically in dosages
of 500 to 1,000 milligrams.
L-Tyrosine is not as potent
in increasing dopamine
as are the prescription drugs
that I referred to before.
Tends to be milder.
For some people it can have
a very amplified effect.
They feel it right away.
It's very intense in
elevating focus and motivation
and the desire to move.
For other people,
it's less potent.
It really depends on
a number of things.
I should mention that regular
consumption of caffeine
of 1 to 3 milligrams per
kilogram of body weight per day
also will increase dopamine
receptor efficacy and density,
which will make any existing
dopamine more effective
whether or not that dopamine
is triggered by things
like L-Tyrosine, or if
you're not taking anything
to elevate dopamine.
The dopamine that
you do make will
be more effective in elevating
your mood, motivation,
and desire to move.
And by extension
divergent thinking.
If you are consuming
caffeine, but, again, caffeine
should be taken prior to
convergent thinking type task
probably more than it
should be taken prior
to divergent thinking task.
And, of course, there are
other legal supplements
that can elevate
dopamine as well
and particular phenethylamine
is very effective in doing that.
600 milligrams of that
has a brief effect lasting
only about 30 to 45 minutes.
But it is one that
many people find
beneficial for sake of studying
or for creative thinking
and so on and so forth.
Now, that's pharmacology.
And in fact, there's
an extensive landscape
of prescription and
supplement based pharmacology
and indeed nutrition.
For instance, the
consumption of foods
that are high in L-Tyrosine
such as aged Parmesan cheese,
for instance, of all things.
Very, very high in L-Tyrosine.
The precursor to dopamine.
Certain foods.
You can look up
online which foods
contain high levels
of L-Tyrosine
and which ones are compatible
with your nutrition.
But leaving pharmacology
aside, there's
a very exciting
nonpharmacological tool.
A purely behavioral tool
that the research literature
has told us can selectively
increase dopamine
within the
nigrostriatal pathway.
The pathway that's involved
in divergent thinking.
And can do so very dramatically
as much as 65% above baseline.
And so this is a
behavioral tool that
is useful for a number of things
but that I find particularly
interesting in leveraging
towards the exploration
and enhancement of creativity
because first of all,
it's purely behavioral.
So it's 0 cost.
And it involves no manipulation
of brain neuromodulators
or chemistry through
pharmacology.
So it's something that you
can explore very safely
and certainly not having
to purchase anything.
And what's really remarkable
is the selectivity
or I think it's fair to
say the immense selectivity
that this particular
behavioral intervention seems
to exert on dopamine within
this pathway associated
with divergent thinking.
So the study that
I'm about to describe
is a study that
dates back 20 years.
Now, that should
not concern you.
In fact, the early arrival
of this study or what
now seems to be early arrival.
I mean, it wasn't that long
ago, is really exciting
because the first
line of this study
really illustrates how important
or how much of a landmark study
this really is.
And so I'll just read you
the first line of the study,
then I'll tell you
the title, then I'll
tell you what they discovered
in fairly top contour
and we will provide
a link to the study
if you want to peruse
it in more detail.
The first line of the study
is this is the first in vivo,
just meaning in the organism.
In this case, this
was a study on humans.
This is the first in
vivo demonstration
of an association between an
endogenous neurotransmitter
release, endogenous means within
us, and conscious experience.
So what this sentence
essentially says
is this is the first study
exploring how a chemical that's
naturally released in our body
relates to a particular quality
of conscious experience.
This study was performed
in Scandinavia,
in one of the
hospitals in Denmark.
Again, we'll provide a link.
The first author is Kjaer.
I think I'm pronouncing it
correctly although probably not
K-J-A-E-R et al.
And the title of the
study is Increased
Dopamine Tone During
Meditation Induced
Change of Consciousness.
And I want to just highlight
that the meditation used
in this study isn't really
a meditation at all.
I don't know why they
selected that for the title.
The behavioral protocol
used in the study
was more akin to what is
normally called yoga nidra
or NSDR nonsleep depressed.
Now yoga nidra and NSDR have
been discussed many times
before on this podcast.
Yoga nidra, for
instance, is a practice
that's been around for hundreds
if not thousands of years
in which people
deliberately lie still.
So they're forcing themselves
to be mostly motionless,
small movements are fine.
And they're directing
their attention
to the surface of
their body, they're
doing long exhale breathing.
Sometimes some intentions,
sometimes some visualization.
But it's really
self-directed relaxation.
And the key component is that
people stay awake and engage
in very little movement.
And the key word
there is movement.
Now, nonsleep depressed is a
acronym, a term that I coined.
It's not a term that
I coined in order
to try and wipe away or
discard with yoga nidra.
I'm a person who has
great respect for yoga
nidra and its traditions.
It's a term that
I coined in order
to encompass a number of
practices that don't include
any mystical type language
or scientific language
for that matter.
And that doesn't
involve intentions.
It involves deep relaxation
yet remaining wide awake
and conscious.
Sometimes people fall
asleep and that's OK.
But this is really an
atypical brain state
of being deeply relaxed yet in
general awake and motionless.
Again, motionless being the key.
Very few brain states involve us
being mostly if not completely
motionless and yet awake.
And it turns out that
brain state whether or not
you call it yoga nidra,
you call it NSDR,
whether or not you call it
meditation induced shift
in consciousness as
they did in this study,
although they do
refer to yoga nidra,
all refer to the same thing,
which is being motionless
and yet aware and relaxed.
I should mention.
So in this study,
what they did was
they subjects into
the laboratory.
They had them either undergo
this self-directed deep
relaxation while they are
motionless or mostly motionless
or they had them listen
to an audio script
while also just lying
there with eyes closed.
And then they used a
number of chemical tricks.
And I don't want to
get too deep into those
now because they can be
a little bit distracting.
For those of you
that are interested,
you can look at it in the study.
This is a binding of a
chemical in the brain
that then they can image
with brain imaging, which
is what they did in the study
to evaluate how much dopamine
changed in the brain
and where specifically
in the brain dopamine
changed its levels before,
during, and after this
particular behavioral practice
in one or the other group.
And what they discovered
is that people
who did this deep
relaxation, that
is, self-directed deep
relaxation lying their eyes
closed, relatively motionless
although small movements
of the body or movements of
the head are absolutely fine.
What they observed was a 65%
increase in dopamine release.
Now, here its key.
Dopamine release.
And they observed an increase
in so-called theta activity.
Theta activity is a pattern
of brain wave activity that's
commonly associated
with creative states
and divergent thinking
in particular.
So that's important.
And they observe
that across subjects
specifically in the
nigrostriatal pathway.
This pathway associated
with divergent thinking.
So this is very exciting.
This is a study
that really points
to a behavioral tool that can
be used to selectively elevate
dopamine in the very pathway
that one would want to if they
wanted to engage divergent
thinking for sake
of creative exploration.
There are also a number of key
observations within this study.
First of all, the reduction in
bodily movement was essential.
In fact, when people rated or
when the amount of readiness
for action in their system,
their body was evaluated.
What people found was that
immediately after this practice
they felt very still.
In other words, they felt as
if remaining still was natural.
Now it's not the case
that they couldn't move.
In fact, the
elevation in dopamine
that occurred during
this practice, this yoga
nidra-like nonsleep or
NSDR-like practice, actually
prepared them to be able to
move in a much more dedicated
and robust way afterwards.
But during the practice,
their readiness for action
went way, way down.
Not surprising.
They were pretty
much motionless.
But interestingly, as the
level of readiness for movement
went down, down,
down, down down,
their degree of
visual imagery, that
is, their internal
landscape and their ability
to imagine new things increased.
And in fact, areas
of the brain that
are associated
with visual imagery
such as the visual or
so-called occipital
cortex and the parietal cortex
has been shown in other studies
to ramp up when
people are motionless.
So there seems to be
this inverse relationship
between movement and visual
imagery which makes sense.
When we're moving
we can pay attention
to things in the
outside world, we
tend to be aware of our sensory
environment to varying degrees.
But we don't tend to be very
focused on visual imagery
within our head whereas when we
lie down or sit down and close
our eyes and we are motionless,
the degree of visual imagery
really increases.
Hence, the increase
in divergent thinking
because what
essentially is happening
is the library of
options, the library
of possible interactions
with whatever it
is that you're thinking about.
I gave the example, which
is a trivial one on purpose
of a pen.
But the bank of options
that becomes available
when we are motionless
and when we are limiting
our visualization of
the external world
increases exponentially.
So this is important.
And what it points
to is the fact
that this very simple completely
nonpharmacologic behavioral
practice of lying
down motionless
for some period of time.
And I confess the amount
of time that they use
in the study was quite long.
It was longer than 60 minutes.
But all the data that I'm aware
of in terms of NSDR and yoga
nidra, and there's a
growing body of literature
on these practices
I should mention,
show that even 10
minutes or even better
would be 20 or 30 minutes
of lying motionless
with eyes closed and
allowing the mind to drift,
wherever it happens
to go, but focusing
on relaxing by doing
long exhale breathing,
perhaps doing a body
scan or focusing
your attention on
particular body parts
but not keeping it focused
on any one particular body
part for that long, that general
practice of deep relaxation
while awake and being
relatively motionless really
favors the brain
states associated
with divergent thinking.
And actually
represents an accessing
of the various
components that you would
use during divergent thinking.
And perhaps most
excitingly, it's
associated with this massive
increase, 65% increase
in dopamine release within
the very pathway that
underlies divergent thinking.
So my recommendation
would be for those of you
that are trying to
enhance divergent thinking
and creative ability, that
you would do this practice
at a minimum once per week.
And I should say if you were
going to do it once per week,
I would recommend doing it
for about 20 to 30 minutes.
Some of you might be able to do
it for as long as 60 minutes.
I myself do such a practice
on a daily basis, anywhere
from 10 minutes to 20
minutes, sometimes 30 minutes.
There's an example of an NSDR
script, completely zero cost.
I confess it does
happen to be my voice.
So forgive me in advance.
There are other options of NSDR.
You can go to YouTube,
put NSDR and my name.
Again, completely zero cost.
You can get a sample of
what a 10 minute NSDR
script looks like.
That's through Virtusan,
put that out there.
So thank you Virtusan for
putting that out there
at zero cost.
There are examples of 20 and
30 minute NSDR scripts and yoga
nidra scripts.
Some that I particularly like.
We will also provide a
link to some of those.
Again, those are completely
zero cost for you to explore.
But more important than you
follow any one particular yoga
nidra NSDR script
is that you learn
to take your body and brain into
these states of limited motion,
elevated dopamine within
this particular pathway,
and fairly deep relaxation.
Again, if you happen
to fall asleep,
that's not necessarily
a bad thing,
although the idea
is that you stay
in a shallow plane
of consciousness
or sleep hence the term
nonsleep deep rest.
So in any event, I think this
is a very useful practice
that many people
could benefit from.
And the fact that it's zero
cost and purely behavioral,
I think adds additional
benefit because it's
certainly one that
people could explore
depending on what amount of
time you're willing to commit.
And the research
data on this now
extend beyond this
one individual paper.
And I think is really
exciting because what it says
is as the title and
first line of the paper
suggests is that we
can increase dopamine
using specific types
of meditation induced
consciousness.
And those increases
in dopamine can
be used to increase our
ability to be more creative.
Before moving forward, I
want to make absolutely clear
how it is that you
would use an NSDR a.k.a.
yoga nidra or similar,
the name doesn't really
matter after all, the
practice is what matters,
in order to enhance dopamine
in this nigrostriatal pathway
and enhance divergent thinking.
The key thing to
understand here is
that the period
of motionlessness
and deep relaxation
while awake increases
dopamine in the
nigrostriatal pathway.
It increases mental imagery.
That is, it increases access to
the bank or the library, if you
will, of possible
solutions or elements
to engage in the divergent
thinking process.
But divergent thinking
itself does not
occur during NSDR a.k.a.
yoga nidra.
The NSDR and yoga nidra, a
deep relaxation meditation,
whatever it is you want to call
it, sets a dopaminergic tone.
And that's actually the
appropriate use of the word
dopaminergic tone it
raises the baseline
of dopamine transmission
in that circuitry that
then positions you to
engage in divergent thinking
more effectively.
So the idea would be to
do anywhere from 10 to 20,
maybe 30 minutes, maybe
even as much as an hour,
depending on how much time
you had to dedicate of such
a meditation and NSDR practice.
And then not
necessarily immediately
but within the 5 to 15
minutes following, then
to go into a practice
of divergent thinking
and start doing
creative exploration.
That is to start thinking
about different ways
to combine existing
elements in whatever domain
it is that you want
to achieve creativity.
So the point is that the
divergent thinking itself
is not occurring during the
NSDR or yoga nidra practice.
The NSDR and yoga nidra
practice prepares you
for divergent thinking that
you do in the hour or hours
that follows.
And just to contrast
that with pharmacology,
I am not aware of any specific
dopamine related pharmacology
that would allow us to
selectively increase dopamine
in the very pathway associated
with divergent thinking
and creativity.
Now, there are forms
of pharmacology
that can shift brain
neurotransmitters
and modulators in ways
that favor creativity.
And this is certainly
a topic that we
we'll go into in more
depth in a future episode.
But there's an
exciting study that
was performed just
this last year looking
at the role of serotonin,
another neuromodulator,
in divergent and
convergent thinking.
And it turns out that serotonin
underlies a lot of the brain
activity that's responsible
for both divergent
and for convergent thinking.
And there's one particular
form of pharmacology
which can enhance activation
of the serotonergic pathways
associated with the so-called
5-HT, that's serotonin.
5-HT, that's the abbreviation.
5-HT2A receptor.
Serotonin 2A receptor in
particular brain areas
in ways that favor both
divergent and convergent
thinking.
And the pharmacologic
agent in that case
turns out to be very low
dose or as some of you
may have heard of it referred
to as microdosing of psilocybin.
Now, I do want to say because it
would be entirely inappropriate
for me to not say this, that
in most areas of the world
and particularly in
the United States,
psilocybin is still illegal.
It is not legal.
In some areas it has
been decriminalized
and there are a number of
different clinical trials
occurring now at Johns
Hopkins, at Stanford,
at University of
California, San Francisco,
and elsewhere
exploring psilocybin
for the treatment of
depression, for trauma,
for eating disorders.
Most of those studies focus
on macrodoses of psilocybin
not microdosing.
There are far fewer studies
of microdosing of psilocybin.
And I do have to point
out that psilocybin use
and possession and, of
course, sale is still illegal.
So I would be remiss
if I didn't state that.
However, I will provide
a link to the study that
shows that microdosing
of psilocybin
for a series of weeks
on a daily basis.
So these are dosages
of psilocybin
that do not induce hallucination
and do not massively
shift mood or internal states in
any way that has people feeling
like they are acting
or feeling that
much different although
some people do report
a subjective shift.
Does seem to increase
divergent thinking ability.
But I do want to put a
big asterisks, a highlight
in an underlying beneath the
statement I'm about to make,
which is that pharmacology
of the serotonin system
just as pharmacology
of the dopamine system
is very broadband.
It's a shotgun approach.
You're going to hit
all the circuits
of the brain that
involve serotonin
with microdosing psilocybin.
Although it has some selectivity
for the 5-HT2A receptor
it can attach to other
receptors as well and act there.
This is the same reason why
SSRI, Selective Serotonin
Reuptake Inhibitors can
indeed shift mood and appetite
but it can also shift
libido and other things.
It's because there are
serotonin receptors everywhere,
or I should say many
places, not just in
the areas of the brain that
are associated with mood,
for instance.
And as I mentioned before,
agents, whether or not they
are recreational or illicit
drugs or prescription drugs
or supplements that
increase dopamine will also
be broadband into a number of
different circuits in parallel.
So this is why I always
say behavioral tools really
should come first.
I don't say that because
I dislike pharmacology,
I say that because in many
cases behavioral tools are not
only safer and easier
to titrate to adjust
the duration, et cetera
than is pharmacology,
but also because
they can sometimes
as in the case of
the study we just
described for you more
specificity not less than
pharmacology.
Pharmacology has its
place can be wonderful,
provided safe and
legal, et cetera.
But it can cause a lot of
so-called off target effects.
So for those of you that
are interested in increasing
creativity through
pharmacology, I
would say, stay tuned for
the data on psilocybin
and microdosing psilocybin.
If you are absolutely obsessed
with the idea of microdosing
psilocybin for
enhancing creativity
and you'd like to go
straight to the study,
I will tell you what that
study is and therefore you
can access some of the
specifics in terms of dosages
and protocols, et cetera.
So since I can't
help myself, I'll
just very briefly summarize that
microdosing psychedelic study.
The title of the study,
which was published in 2018
is Exploring the Effect of
Microdosing Psychedelics
on Creativity in an Open
Label Natural Setting.
Interesting title.
This was a microdosing
event organized
by the Dutch
psychedelic society.
They examined the effects
of psychedelic truffles
where they knew what psychedelic
compounds were contained there
on two creativity related
problem solving task,
the picture concept task, which
I don't expect you to recognize
or know but it assesses
convergent thinking
and the alternative
uses task which
I also don't expect
you to know but is
a standard task for
assessing divergent thinking.
They tested once before
taking a microdose
and while the effects were
expected to be manifested
they say.
Interesting.
They use the word manifested
in a study of psychedelics.
Science is changing indeed.
In any case, what they found
was an enhancement of creative.
That is, divergent and
convergent thinking
not surprising given the
fact that the 5-HT2A receptor
activity is increased by
microdosing of psilocybin
and 5-HT2A receptors are present
both on the neural circuits
that underlie divergent
and convergent thinking.
So, again, this is not a plug
for microdosing psilocybin.
This is really in
response to what
I know will be a number of
different questions about what
pharmacologic agents can be
used to increase creativity.
So more on that later
and, again, we'll
provide a link if you want to
read that study in more depth.
I can imagine that
a number of you
are probably also wondering
about the effects of alcohol
and the effects of
cannabis on creativity.
We did a long in-depth
episode all about alcohol
and its effects on health.
The bottom line on
alcohol is that in excess
of two drinks per
week, you're starting
to run into the cancer promoting
and toxic effects of alcohol.
I didn't choose for
the answer to be that,
but that's what
the data tell us.
I'm not telling you you can't
drink more than two drinks
per week, I'm just saying that
if you're going to do that,
you should really
consider offsetting
that with some other
behavioral measures
all discussed in the
episode on alcohol.
And despite what
people think, there
is absolutely zero evidence that
alcohol increases creativity.
However, by way of
reducing activation
of the prefrontal cortex,
there is some evidence
that alcohol and
other substances
that reduce what's called
autobiographical scripting,
that is, a narrative
about ourselves,
so self awareness, that it
can enhance divergent thinking
at very low doses.
And this makes sense.
Divergent thinking involves
remembering certain things
that we can use as elements
in the creative process
but suppressing narratives
about what the use of those
would mean.
Will people like it?
Will they not like it?
Will it to the outcome we want?
Well, it won't.
All of that
autobiographical scripting
involves the forebrain
being very, very active
and specific regions of the
forebrain in particular.
And that all needs
to be suppressed,
which alcohol in very
low doses can accomplish.
But, again, that's not
a plug for alcohol.
I think behavioral tools
would be a much better route.
But therefore it
shouldn't be surprising
why some people have used
low dose alcohol in order
to engage in the
creative process
because it involves
less inhibition
or sense of self that could be
detrimental to the divergent
thinking process.
Now, with respect to
cannabis, I went in depth
into the biology and the
various uses, misuses,
dangers, and in some cases
benefits of cannabis use
in certain.
The key word there is
certain populations.
And I also dove
into whether or not
cannabis can be used to increase
divergent and convergent
thinking.
So that's timestamped
in that episode.
I'll refer you to that episode.
But the long and short of
it is that many of the ideas
that people come up with when
under the influence of cannabis
in particular high THC
containing cannabis does lead
to enhanced divergent
thinking, but so enhanced
it turns out that
oftentimes those ideas can't
be constrained by the
convergent thinking process.
In other words, they
have lots of ideas
that make sense while under
the influence of cannabis.
But that later cannot be
implemented into a coherent
framework that leads to any
actual creative endeavor
or creative product.
Or, as is often the
case with cannabis,
they simply can't remember
what they were thinking about.
Any time there's a
discussion about dopamine,
there seems to be a discussion
about motivation, desire,
and drive.
And, of course, that makes sense
given the roles of dopamine.
We did an entire episode
on dopamine, motivation,
and drive.
It's one of our most
popular episodes.
Again, you can access that
with timestamps and all formats
at hubermanlab.com.
And any time
there's a discussion
about dopamine and
motivation, we also
seem to have a lot of questions
about attention and focus
and ADHD or attention
deficit hyperactivity
disorder in particular.
So just as a brief
mention, there
is a literature although
not terribly extensive,
a small but strong literature
on the relationship
between ADHD and creativity.
And the long and short
of that literature
is that people who have
ADHD regardless of age
do seem to have an
ability to focus.
I've mentioned that
in the episode on ADHD
provided that they are
interested in the thing
that they are focusing on.
So that runs counter to this
idea that people with ADHD
simply can't focus.
They can but it tends to be a
focus that selective for things
that they are very excited about
or interested in as opposed
to a general ability to focus.
What's also highly
underappreciated
is that people who
have ADHD oftentimes
are very effective
at divergent thinking
but are less effective
at convergent thinking.
What this tells us is
that people with ADHD
can often have excellent novel
and indeed creative ideas,
but that the implementation
of those creative ideas
is sometimes challenge.
And that's one reason to
explore rational pharmacology,
nutrition,
supplementation, et cetera.
Those are all things
to explore in concert
with or I should say in
working closely with a board
certified physician or ideally
psychiatrist expert in ADHD.
You can also check out the
episode that we did on ADHD.
There are a lot of tools there.
A lot of science mentioned
there to support those tools.
Again, you can find
that Hubermanlab.com.
But I did think it was
important to point out,
even if briefly that having ADHD
is not a barrier to creativity
and, in fact, may actually be
an enhanced portal to creativity
but that it doesn't
allow people to access
the convergent thinking that
allows creative ideas to be
implemented into specific
strategies, pressure tested,
and eventually delivered in
the form of a final product
of music, art, et cetera.
That is not to say that people
with ADHD cannot accomplish
that, but that it is going to
require some additional steps
and protocols in order to
enhance convergent thinking.
And that episode and
the episode that we
did on focus and in particular
tools to enhance focus
is very much directed at ways
to enhance convergent thinking.
So if you have ADHD or
know somebody who does
and you're interested
in the creative process,
we're focusing generally
please check out the episodes
that I mentioned.
Now, there's also a small
but nonetheless very exciting
literature on the relationship
between physical movement
and divergent thinking.
This should come as
no surprise to us.
As mentioned many times
now in this episode,
the nigrostriatal pathway
involved in divergent thinking
that involves dopamine is also
responsible for eye blinks
and for movements of the
limbs of the body in very
deliberate ways.
This tells us that there's
some direct or maybe
indirect relationship
between movement
of the body and
divergent thinking.
And despite the fact that
it's only a few studies,
there have been some studies
of whether or not people are
able to engage in
divergent thinking
more effectively when
they are doing things
like pacing or walking.
And this could be on a
treadmill or back and forth
across the room.
And in fact, that is
absolutely the case.
If you're somebody
like myself who
tends to have their
best ideas, not
saying that my ideas are always
terrific, but among the ideas
I have, some of the better
ones arrive to me while
on my long Sunday run.
I tend to do a long
run or hike on Sundays
sometimes with a light weight
vest or something of that sort.
But when I'm in a state
of essentially not
directing my attention
to any one thing
in my external environment, this
is extremely key for reasons
that now should be obvious.
Any time we are
directing our attention
to a visual target
or an auditory target
we are not as able to engage
in divergent thinking.
This is why I will
sometimes listen
to podcasts or to audiobooks
while I go on these runs.
But for portions of
these runs or hikes
I tend to turn those off and
just focus on the movement
and focus on not focusing
on anything in particular.
And oftentimes I will stop and
write down ideas that suddenly
or seemingly suddenly appear
to me or geyser to the surface.
I'll have an idea.
Sometimes those are good ideas,
sometimes less good ideas.
The fact that happens
for me and the fact
that many people are
pacers or runners
or come up with their best
ideas while in the shower
or while engaging in
activities that don't require
a lot of sensory
attention to one
specific location either
visual or auditory,
et cetera, that is because it
engages these nigrostriatal
pathways through movement
which then opens up
this library of ideas and
allows the intersection
of different ideas that
normally would be constrained
to separate categories.
One way to think
about this by analogy
would be when I was a kid
you'd go to the library,
nowadays you just go online.
But the different pages
of different books
on different topics are kept
distinct from one another.
That is bound by different
book covers and book
ends, different
shelves in the library.
It's as if different pages
and elements from those books
are now being combined
in a pseudo random.
Not random but in a
pseudo random way.
And in that combination,
new possibilities
about ways that information
could be combined
and implemented start to arise.
So the tool that emerges
from this is very simple.
And it won't necessarily
apply to everybody.
But if you are
somebody who finds
that just sitting in a chair
and trying to be creative
is very challenging, some
of you might benefit from,
for instance, if
you are engaging
in writing or you want to
write to talk into the voice
recorder of your phone while
walking or simply walking
and not attending to any
one specific thing visually
or through headphones.
And then as ideas
surface, seemingly
out of nowhere, which
is how it happens,
that you could either
put them into your phone
by voice dictation or you could
type them out if you like.
The key thing is to
not be distracted
by other things
in your phone, not
to start going onto social
media or doing phone calls
or looking at text messages
because that by definition
is going to take you out
of this what biologists
call a pseudo random walk.
And this pseudo random element
is extremely important.
We know, for instance, that
many circuits within the brain
have what's called dedicated
point to point wiring.
So, for instance,
the brain circuits
that govern your breathing.
The brain circuits that
govern your heartbeat.
govern your specific movements
once you are an adult and allow
for smooth directed movement
are very precise, very little
slop if any in the wiring.
However, there are aspects of
your brain circuitry, yours
and everybody
else's I should say,
that are maintained
into adulthood that
include a lot of extra wiring.
And these are fine wires.
They are not the major highways
between different areas,
if you will.
So like Google Maps has highways
and streets and little passages
and alleys.
But it's as if
there's a little web
of additional possible pathways
cast over that entire thing.
The human brain maintains
such webs of possible passage.
And it's only during activities
such as walking, running,
cycling, swimming,
hiking, pacing, et
cetera that the activation of
those pseudo random pathways
starts to ramp up.
So this is a purely
behavioral approach
to engaging different elements
within neural networks that
normally would not
communicate with one another
when we are completely still.
So again, the
practices that I talked
about earlier of being
completely still to raise
dopamine and enhanced
divergent thinking--
I just want to
reemphasize are designed
to position you to
ready you to engage
in the activities like
walking and pacing,
et cetera, that best
facilitate divergent thinking.
So if you are somebody who wants
to enhance divergent thinking,
I would encourage
you to explore how
different patterns of movement
in particular, patterns
of movement that don't require
any conscious attention
to any one specific thing
allow you to access new ideas
and new ways of combining
existing elements
in whatever domain it is
you want to be creative.
Now, this is also an opportunity
to underscore something
I said back at the
beginning, which
is you are not going to come
up with great works of music
if you don't understand
chords and melodies and notes
and music.
Those basic elements
have to be built up
through some formal or at least
rigorous or regular training.
In the same way that you're
not going to take a walk,
and then suddenly
be able to paint
an incredible picture if you
have no painting ability.
That is not going to happen.
What I'm talking
about here are ways
to enhance your capacity
for divergent thinking,
such as NSDR and ways to
engage in divergent thinking,
such as through certain forms
of movement that don't require
a lot of conscious attention
to your surroundings or any one
specific sensory target.
And in doing so,
enhancing your ability
to be more creative in a
domain for which you already
have some degree of
skill or even mastery.
Now, in keeping with
the theme of how
to enhance our
creativity, there's
a very exciting and yet parallel
literature to the literature
that I've been
describing thus far.
Now, I promise you
that I'm not going
to open up an entire
library of new information
related to neural
circuits and so forth.
But I would be remiss
if I didn't mention
this parallel literature because
it speaks very specifically
to some important practices
that we can all use in order
to enhance creativity.
And to do so the first
time and every time.
And this is really because
certain scientists out there
have really gone
through the trouble.
I should even say the
painstaking trouble
of really trying to dissect
what the creative process is
both for individuals and
in groups or even in pairs.
And so what I'm about to tell
you is beautifully encapsulated
in an article entitled--
"A new method for
training creativity--
narrative as an alternative
to divergent thinking."
So again, we've been talking
about divergent thinking.
That's one pathway into
the creative process
but there are others as well.
And as it turns
out, they're not so
distinct in terms of the
underlying brain mechanisms.
Nonetheless, let
me describe briefly
how narrative can be
used to train creativity
and to become more creative.
And in order to
do that, I'd like
to just briefly
paraphrase or read
from the first
paragraph of this paper.
So what I'm about to read are
the author's words, not mine.
Quote "Here's a paradox.
According to current
research young children
are more imaginatively
creative than adults."
And indeed that is
true, by the way.
"Yet also according
to current research,
creativity is main neural
engine is divergent thinking,
which relies on memory
and logical association
to tasks at which young
children underperform adults."
That is, children are not as
good at divergent thinking
as adults are.
So how could it
be the authors are
asking that children are
more imaginative and thus
more creative than adults.
This can only mean that
there are alternate pathways
to creativity.
And indeed that is the case.
And so what this
paper really explores
is other ways to
access creativity.
And what they describe is
what's called narrative theory.
And there's a number
of different aspects
to this narrative theory.
But they agree that the standard
definition of creativity
is the same one that we
were talking about before.
So we're not talking about a
different form of creativity,
here we're talking
about a different way
to access creativity.
They describe the standard
definition of creativity
as quote "The
ability to generate
novel ideas that are useful."
So the commonly accepted one.
And what they cite as the
basis for narrative theory
is this breakthrough
finding in the 1950s.
This is the work of Guilford
Some people out there
might be familiar with it.
I was not at the outset of
researching this episode.
What this theory from
Guilford essentially states
is that there are different
intellectual capacities that
are not captured by
standard IQ tests.
I think that's generally
accepted nowadays.
We know there's
emotional intelligence,
we know the standard
IQ, et cetera.
But the important
element to understand
is that these authors
were able to trace back
the idea of narrative
training as a way
to enhance creativity long
before Guilford in the 1950s,
all the way back to Aristotle.
So this is incredible.
Narrative theory
was actually birthed
in 335 BCE in his
writing called Poetics,
which I think is
incredible at least to me
that people long before us
were thinking about creativity
and what goes into creativity.
And what Aristotle said, what
Guilford then elaborated on
and what the authors
of this paper
further elaborate
on and actually have
developed training
protocols for,
is the idea that there are
three elements that we can use
in order to enhance creativity.
And those three
elements are what's
called world
building, I'll explain
what these are in a moment,
perspective shifting,
and action generating.
And right off the
bat, the word action
should raise a flag for you.
And by that I mean a positive
flag because once again,
we are back into the world and
therefore the neural circuits
of movement and motion.
So three elements of world
building perspective, shifting,
and active generating are
what make up this narrative
approach to creativity.
And I should mention that
these authors and others are
using such approach with
companies, with groups,
with individuals.
So this is using a bunch
of different contexts
to approach and enhance
different forms of creativity.
So let's talk first about
world building techniques.
This is going to be
immediately familiar to you
when you hear it.
But one of the key elements of
creativity is to at the outset
come up with some idea
that makes sense or is
attractive to you about how
the world is different inside
of your creative endeavor.
So for those that
write science fiction
or think about
science fiction, there
are some obvious
aspects to this.
But for those of you
that don't, maybe you
come up with a
narrative, for instance,
in the context of storytelling
that in your world
we are the house
cats and the cats
are actually the ones that
are the curators of the Earth.
OK.
So right there, there
is a conceptual shift
that the world in which
whatever creative idea is going
to emerge is entirely
different than the one
that we actually live in.
So that sets a certain number
of important constraints.
It means certain things
are now possible,
other things are
not possible that
are very different from
the world that we live in.
You can see the parallels here
to childhood imagination where
essentially anything can
happen in the child's mind
because they are unconstrained.
The second element
is this perspective
shifting techniques.
And the idea here is
that not only are we
supposed to have the reader or
the listener or the observer
or us explore for creativity
and develop a creative idea
by thinking differently
which is a generic term.
How do we actually
think differently.
But rather than just say take
the perspective of somebody
else in terms of what
they would see or do
or say or think
rather, we are supposed
to think about their
underlying motivation.
So we could do the world shift,
that is the world structure
shift from step one.
And then in step two, you
would ask yourself OK,
rather than write about
or think about or move
from the perspective
of myself, let's say,
you're feeling particularly
happy that day.
You'd say, I'm actually
going to take the perspective
of somebody who's angry.
But rather than
just act angry, I'm
going to think about what their
motivation for being angry is.
Maybe they had a breakup.
Maybe they were jealous.
Maybe somebody had
wronged them in some way.
Maybe they're just generally
angry at the world for whatever
reason and then operate from
that motivational stance.
And this is a very
interesting and powerful step
because what it really
captures at least
as viewed by me,
the neuroscientists,
is it captures a whole set
of neural circuits about what
that motivational state means
because motivational states
dictate a huge number of
possible different outcomes,
but they really constrain the
number of different actions
and outcomes that any
of us would engage in.
Rather than saying I'm going
to view the world the way
that someone else
will view the world,
by stating that we are
going to be motivated
by their set of motivations
and not our own,
it includes a lot more
possibilities and yet not
an infinite number
of possibilities.
They are constrained
in a logical way,
which is one of the key
elements of creativity.
And then the third
element, which
is action generating techniques
is a really cool one that you
will immediately
notice implications
for the workplace, which
is forced collaboration.
So inside of this thing
that we're building here,
this story, you create a
novel rule for the world
that your story is
going to exist in
or your music is going to exist
in or your sport will exist in.
Then you create this
perspective shift
where you take on the
motivation of someone
else different than
you and then you
force collaboration
between that person who
has this alternate
motivation different from you
and someone else who has an
entirely different motivation.
And in doing so,
you create these
what are called the
creative collisions.
Now they're collisions because
they're crossing one another
and something new has
to emerge from them.
They could be antagonistic.
They could be arguments
fighting physical or verbal
or Otherwise they
could be synergistic.
They could take on any
number of different forms
depending on the motivations
and the individuals that
are involved.
But even though I
just described this
in fairly top contour,
what I just described
is actually the core
elements of any story
or any creative endeavor.
It's just that many stories are
from the perspective of what
we already know and believe
and think the world to be.
And our own perspective
and the actions
that we would take given that
world in that perspective.
Whereas if we want
to be creative,
we want to think outside
of our usual framework
and yet using elements
that exist within us
no one has to tell us
the creative narrative.
We're trying to come
up with it on our own.
We want to essentially
think in a childlike way
how do children think?
Well, they have new
different or entirely novel
concepts about how
the world works.
But those are bounded.
And this is a key word.
Those are bounded.
They're not infinite.
It's not that
anything can happen.
Some kids will say, you can fly
and you can shoot lasers out
of your eyes, you
can do all things
that are unicorns or candy
falling from the sky.
At some point, if you don't
bound the change in the world,
it just becomes pure chaos and
even children don't do that.
So we need to bound the
change and yet create
some alternate universe, if you
will, in which the story takes
place or the
creation of any kind,
doesn't have to be
a story takes place.
Then there has to be
a perspective shift.
And this is very useful.
This is actually a
tool that we can all
use of trying to take
the perspective of others
but not just asking what they
would feel or think or do.
But ask what is their
motivation in life generally
or what mood stance or goal
stance are they taking.
Are they trying to
extract from others?
Are they trying
to give to others?
Are they very altruistic,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then you take
that individual
and you do that also for
another individual or group
of individuals
and then you start
thinking about how those
different individuals because
of their different
motivational states
would engage at the
level of action.
What they would do,
what they would say,
would they mate,
would they fight,
would they-- et
cetera, et cetera.
You think of any story.
The story of Star Wars,
of the Greek myths.
You think of any story that has
been created, which we consider
great and novel works.
And you start to find these
three elements-- worldbuilding,
perspective shifting, and
action generating techniques.
And so while this is, again,
just a broad contour of what
this narrative
approach involves,
I think it's a very
important and very exciting
one because it
gives us a formula.
We already know that
divergent thinking
and convergent thinking
are both elements
of the creative process.
This is suggesting
that whether or not
it involves divergent
thinking or not,
these authors seem
to think this is
distinct from divergent
thinking that capturing some
of the elements of creativity
that are present in childhood
but that then tend to
disappear as we start
to assume identity, build
identity, and understand rules
about the actual
world we live in.
All of those basic elements
of early childhood creativity
can be reawakened.
And, in fact, they have data
to support the fact that they
can be reawakened in
adults in meaningful ways
that can lead to new product
design, new workplace
interactions, and on and on.
That I find very exciting.
And as a consequence,
I do intend
to do an entire episode
at some point on narrative
and storytelling.
And the role of narrative
and storytelling
not just for sake of
creativity but also
for accessing neuroplasticity
and for enhancing memory
and so on.
There's an entire landscape of
literature and exciting tools
and things to understand there.
But in the meantime, we will
provide a link to this paper.
And for those of you that
choose not to access the paper,
simply understanding these
three aspects of narrative
as an alternative to
accessing creativity.
That is, a dedicated and well
understood or established
world shift that you choose,
perspective shifting and taking
on the motivation of
others, and creating
some landscape of exploration
for what interactions would
occur between that individual
or groups of individuals
and other individuals that
have other motivations
and yet are still living
in this alternate world.
Those three elements
we now know can
be combined into what
you or I or anyone
would consider important
creative works.
So today we
discussed creativity.
This absolutely fascinating
aspect to human brain
function that has allowed us as
a species to develop everything
from great works
of art and music
to technological innovations
that allow us to fly and allow
us to access people all over
the world through little screen
devices that we carry around
in our pockets and on and on.
As I mentioned at the
beginning of today's episode,
I find creativity to be one of
the most fascinating aspects
of brain function.
And in particular,
because we don't actually
know what the upper
limits of creativity
are and yet we understand
that there are certain bounds,
there are certain requirements.
And the key requirement
for creativity
is this aspect of utility.
Now, that doesn't
necessarily mean
that for something to
be considered creative
it has to be useful in
the practical sense,
but it does seem
that for something
to be considered truly
creative or especially creative
in some cases that
it revealed to us
something fundamental about the
way that we or the world works.
We discuss some of the
neural circuits that
underlie the different
aspects of creativity
in particular divergent
and convergent thinking
as well as narrative building
and some of the tools
and steps that can allow
us to better access
divergent thinking and
convergent thinking.
And those tools include
behavioral tools as well as
pharmacology.
And we talked about narrative
building as a way to reawaken
or I should say, reaccess
the childhood creativity
that did indeed exist in all
of us at some point in time.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a five star review.
If you have questions for us
or comments about the podcast
or suggestions about
guests that you'd
like us to interview on
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all the comments.
Please also check
out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
and at various times
during today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
As I mentioned at the
beginning of today's podcast,
we've partnered with
Momentous supplements
because Momentous supplements
are the very highest quality.
They have single
ingredient formulations
which turns out to be
most effective in building
a supplement protocol.
And when I say most
effective I mean,
most biologically effective
and most cost effective.
And we're fortunate that
they ship internationally
because we know that many of
you reside outside of the United
States.
If you want to check out
the supplements mentioned
in today's and in other episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
supplements that are
aimed at enhancing sleep,
enhancing focus, hormone
support, et cetera,
you can go to live
momentous spelled O-U-S.
So its
livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you haven't already
subscribed to the Huberman Lab
podcast Neural
Network Newsletter,
this is a monthly newsletter
that is completely
zero cost that has summaries
of particular podcast episodes
as well as toolkits for things
like enhancing sleep, enhancing
focus, dopamine, deliberate cold
exposure, and many other topics
important to you, the listeners
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
If you'd like to
join the newsletter,
please go to hubermanlab.com,
click on the Menu
and go to a newsletter.
You provide your email to us.
We do not share your
email with anybody else.
And as I already mentioned,
it is completely zero cost.
If you're not
already following us
on Instagram, Twitter, or
Facebook and/or LinkedIn,
please do so.
It is Huberman Lab
on all platforms.
On all those social
media platforms,
I describe science and science
related tools, some of which
overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast
but often which does not
overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
Again, its Huberman
Lab on all platforms.
So thank you once
again for joining me
for today's discussion
all about the science
and tools for creativity.
And last but
certainly not least,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]